İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 30 Aralık 2024 Pazartesi günü. Evet 2024 yılının son dersi diyebiliriz değil mi? Yanlış olmaz.
52. ders günümüz. Dersimize başlıyoruz. Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Efendim nerede kaldığımızı hemen hatırlıyoruz. Akıllı pointerlar. İngilizcesi ile Smart Pointers.
Önce akıllı pointerların neden gerektiği üstünde epey konuştuk. Sonra da Smart Pointer sınıflarımızı yani STL'de Smart Pointer hizmeti veren iki tane sınıfı göreceğiz dedik.
Bir de yardımcı sınıfımız var. Kendisi bence akıllı pointer değil ama akıllı pointer yardımcısı. Onun ismi de WIC-PTR idi.
Unique PTR, Shared PTR ve WIC-PTR bu üç sınıfı bilmemiz, tanımamız gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlar bu arada hemen şunu söyleyelim. Bunlar programlama dili içinde detaylar mı yoksa programlama dili içindeki bazı detaylar mı yoksa üretimde sürekli kullanacağımız araçlar mı?
Cevap ikincisi. Evet evet şimdi diyor ki Alihan geçen dersin son kısmını özetleyeceğinizi söylemiştiniz.
Tabii ki özetleyeceğim. Üstelik zaten biraz daha geri aldım. Nerede kaldığımızı hatırlayalım diye.
Unique PTR sınıfı ne yapıyordu?
Exclusive Ownership stratejisini implement ediyordu.
Yani bir kaynağın, bir nesnenin bir sahibi olur.
O sahibin hayatı bittiğinde o kaynak geri verilir ve ikinci bir pointer bizim nesnemizi gösteremez, kaynağımızı gösteremez.
Ancak bir pointer mülkiyeti devrettikten sonra ikinci pointer onu gösterebilir dedik.
Arkadaşlar böylece A, Unique PTR nesnesinin destraktörünün çağrılması durumunda eğer hayatını kontrol ettiği bir nesne varsa onu delete ediyor.
Böylece RAI idiomunun en tipik örneğini gerçekleştirmiş oluyoruz.
Yani dinamik ömürlü nesneleri bizim sonlandırmamız gerekmiyor.
Exception safety konusunda önemli bir avantaj sağlıyor dedik.
Arkadaşlar ve dangling pointer oluşumunu da bir şekilde kontrol ediyoruz dikkatli olursak.
O zaman bizim default seçimimiz Unique PTR, dinamik ömürlü nesneleri ya da kaynakları kontrol etmek için.
Unique PTR sınıfı bir sınıf şablonuydu.
İşte Alihan Bey'in tekrar eder misiniz dediği yer burası.
Birinci template parametresi hayatı kontrol edilecek nesnenin türü, ikinci template parametresi arkadaşlar deleter türü.
Ne yapıyordu?
Aslında bir Unique PTR nesnesi hayatı bittiğinde ikinci template parametresi türünden bir nesneyi kullanarak arkadaşlar o nesnenin fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonuna neyi gönderiyor?
Sarmaladığı adresi gönderiyor.
Eğer Un'un kodu dedik delete şeklindeyse ki default delete onu gerçekleştiriyordu.
Böylece sonlandırma pointer'ı dolayısıyla dinamik ömürlü nesneyi delete etmek yoluyla gerçekleşiyordu.
Öyle değil mi?
Şimdi biraz işin içine girelim.
Şöyleydi değil mi?
Template typename t, typename d eşittir arkadaşlar.
Stude default delete'in t açılımı.
İşte default delete'in t açılımını template argümanı olarak seçersek o zaman arkadaşlar biz şöyle bir sınıf tasarladığımızda Unique PTR.
Unique PTR'ın Construct Distractor'ı ne yapıyordu?
Burası ben de önemli.
Aslında burada sarmalanan bir adres var.
T yıldız MP ve destractor'ın da kodu şöyle olsun arkadaşlar.
Filda Unique PTR.
Dedik ki normalde açanki seviyesinde herkesin beklediği şöyle bir kod.
Eğer MP null pointer değilse delete MP.
Eğer böyle olsaydı dedik o zaman sadece ve sadece kaynağı bu şekilde sonlandırma imkanı olurdu.
Oysa böyle değil.
Nasıl arkadaşlar aslında burada diyelim ki D türünden bir nesne oluşturuluyor.
Bu bir yakın sama.
Bunun fonksiyonu çağrı operatör fonksiyonuna MP argüman olarak gönderiliyor.
Default delete'in kodu da nasıl?
Struct.
Efendim diyelim ki struct.
Default delete.
Bu da bir sınıf şamlını.
Temp etlerken MP.
Ama bunun şöyle bir fonksiyonu var.
Void.
Operatör fonksiyon çağrı.
E yıldız arkadaşlar.
Ve kodu da delete.
H.
İşte delete edilmesini istiyorsak doğrudan template parametresine karşılık gelen default template argümanını kullanabiliriz dedik.
Ama bazı durumlarda kaynağı sonlandırılmak A delete etme yoluyla istenmiyor.
B belki ilave bir takım işlemler yapılması gerekiyor.
İşte en tipik iki tane örnek dedik.
Arkadaşlar mesela bakınız.
Geçen derste kaldığımız yer burası Dijitanyan.
Dedim ki böyle bir kod olsaydı file yıldız f eşittir fopen alihan.txt write modunda sonra bu dosyaya cstd.io'yu da include edelim.
Belki bir takım veriler yazdık.
F print f.
F.
Alihan.
Oskar.
Ve dosyayı kapattık.
Burada da kullandığımız bir kaynak var dosya.
Ya burada örneğin.
Çağırdığımız bir fonksiyon.
Arkadaşlar.
Eksepşon rov ederse bu durumda programın akışı eksepşonu yakalayan koda yönlendirilecek.
Dolayısıyla arkadaşlar bunların herhangi bir fonksiyon olduğunu düşünün.
Dolayısıyla kaynak sızıntısı olacak.
Ama bu API'yi ben oluşturmadım ki.
Şimdi dedik ki peki nasıl engelleriz bunu?
Unique PTR'ı bu amaçla kullanabilir miyiz?
Aslına bakarsanız burada.
A.
Unique PTR'ı doğrudan kullanabilirim.
B.
Henüz size anlatmadığım.
Standart kütüphanede olmayan ama kolaylıkla implemente edebileceğimiz.
Popüler olarak Scope Guard denilen sınıflar türünden nesnede kullanabilirim.
Ama konumuz şimdi Scope Guard değil.
Şimdi biz Unique PTR'la nasıl engelleriz bu durumu ona bakalım.
Arkadaşlar bakın şimdi zaten ben burada Alihan özellikle siz dikkat edin.
Zaten ben burada bir pointer değişken kullanmıyor muyum?
Evet.
Unique PTR'da böyle bir pointer değişkeni alternatif değil mi?
O zaman pek yapmam gereken, bakın yavaş yavaş gidiyorum.
Unique PTR'ın memory başlık dosyası.
Unique PTR'ın file açılımı.
Türünden bir nesne oluşturmalı.
Unique PTR'ın file açılımı türünden bir nesnenin sarmaladığı pointer file yıldız.
Ama bir problemimiz var.
Tamam şimdi ben bu dosyayı kullanabilirim.
Ama bu nesnenin hayatı bittiğinde eğer bu şekilde kodu yazsaydım delete pointer yapacaktı.
Oysa ben bir delete ifadesi kullanmak yerine sonlandırmanın F-close fonksiyonuna yapılan çareyle yapılmasını istiyorum.
Peki o zaman ne yapacağım arkadaşlar?
Bir custom deleteer kullanacağım.
Bu arada Yiğit'sinin sorunuza da cevap vereceğim ama sorunuzun cevabı aslında burada da var.
Bakınız öyle bir deleteer olmalı ki bir file nesnesinin adresini aldığında onu F-close'a argüman olarak göndermeli.
Bunu örneğin bir lambda ifadesinden elde edilecek closure type'la yapabilirim.
İster şöyle yazın.
Auto F-D eşittir.
File Yıldız F-Stude F-Close F.
İşte bakın çağrılacak fonksiyon bu fonksiyon olacak.
Ama bu fonksiyonun çağrılabilmesi için ikinci template parametresinin Yiğit F-D'nin türü neyse o türden olması gerekir.
Dolayısıyla benim kullanmam gereken template argümanı F-D değişkeninin türü olan closure type.
İşte F-D değişkeninin türünü de decal type specifier ile bu şekilde elde edebiliyorum.
Burası arkadaşlar anlaşıldı mı?
Evet böylece bakın Unique PTR nesnesinin hayata bittiğinde ne olacak?
Bu fonksiyon çağrılacak.
Yiğit burada anlamadığımız bir şey var mı?
Şimdi isterseniz önce koda devam edelim.
Dedik ki yalnız burada bir şeye de dikkat etmemiz gerekiyor.
Şimdi artık normalde Unique PTR nesnesini doğrudan pointer olarak kullanıyoruz.
Ama bize şimdi sarmalanan file yıldız değeri gerekiyor.
Örneğin F-Print'e fonksiyonu benden o file pointer'ını istiyor.
İşte o file pointer'ını elde etmek için de sınıfın get fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum.
Hatta demiştim ki işte get fonksiyonunun önemi de burada ortaya çıkıyor.
Efendim Alihan Bozkır yazısını yazdıralım.
Ve bakın artık us'yayı kapatmak benim görevim değil.
Ne zamanki buradaki UP nesnesinin hayatı bitiyor.
O zaman arkadaşlar ne olacak?
Destructor çağırılacak.
Unique PTR'in destructor'ı da buradaki fonksiyona sarmaladığı pointer'ı gönderecek.
Şimdi Yiğit B için değil sadece bütün arkadaşlarımız için söylüyorum.
Önce bunu bir derleyelim.
Eksik bir şey kalmasın.
Ve çalıştıralım arkadaşlar.
Tabii main fonksiyonu içinde.
Bar fonksiyonunu çağıralım.
Başka eksik bir şey kaldı mı?
Hayır.
Ve gerçekten dosyanın A kapatıldığını arkadaşlar.
B var fonksiyonunu çağırdık.
Autofege'de.
Unique PTR file legal type fprintf up yet.
Arkadaşlar Alihan Bozkır dosya oluşturmamışız.
Onu da yazalım.
Evet.
Arkadaşlar.
Unique PTR file dosya oluşturmamışız.
O satır silinmiş.
File yıldız.
F eşittir.
F open.
Alihan.
Arkadaşlar Bozkır.
Bozkır.
Şimdi ister bunu böyle yazın.
İster doğrudan F open'a.
Right by right.
İşte bu ifadenin geri dönüş değeri zaten file yıldız.
Ve argüman olarak F open'ın geri dönüş değerini verdim.
Öyle değil mi?
Evet.
Şimdi.
Muhtemelen kafanızın karıştığı yer burası değil.
Orayı da açıklayacağım.
Hiç merak etmeyin.
Önce bunu derleyip çalıştıralım.
Ve arkadaşlar.
Alihan.t
Alihan Bozkır.
Uzantısını tx'e yapmamışım.
Hadi tx'e yapayım.
Bir kez daha çalıştırayım.
Bir editörümü açsın kolaylıkla.
Alihan Bozkır tx'de.
Yazma modunda.
Evet.
Çalıştırdık.
Dosya uzantısını mı göstermiyorum?
Olabilir.
Evet.
Burası mı?
Yok.
Burası değil.
Evet.
Burası.
in.cpp
Değiştirme tarihi.
Yanlış yere basmışım.
Evet.
Burada dosya.
Dosyaya bakalım.
Arkadaşlar.
Hatta şuradan açalım.
Biraz bekleteceğim.
Şu can sıkıcı işlemleri için.
Add.
existingitem.
Existingitem.
Alihan Bozkır nokta tx'de.
Ve açtık.
Gerçekten dosyaya yazmış.
Şimdi.
Önce bitireyim isterseniz Mehmet Çan Bey.
Hemen sizin sorunuza da cevap vereyim.
Arkadaşlar şuralarda kafanız karışmış olabilir.
Bakınız.
Biraz.
Hızlı vakitlanırsanız anlatacağım.
Şimdi bir.
Burada eğer C++20 olmasaydı o zaman bu tür durumlarda fonksiyona diliter nesnesinde argüman olarak geçmemiz gerekecekti.
Nedenini hatırlıyorsunuz arkadaşlar.
Çünkü default constructible değil de lambdalar.
Stakeless lambdalar.
İki.
Şurada da kafamız karışmış olabilir.
Yine C++20 standartında lambda ifadelerinin unevaluated kontekste kullanılma imkanı geldi.
Dolayısıyla böyle yazmak yerine.
Hadi gelin şunu pek satır yapalım.
Böyle yazmak yerine arkadaşlar bunu doğrudan alıp şurada decal type'ın argümanı olarak verebilirim.
İşte buradaki özellik yani bu şekilde yazabilmem C++20 standartıyla gelen benim lambdaları anlatırken belki anlatmadığım C++20 ile ilgili olduğu için
Lambda expressions in unevaluated kontekst.
O başlık altında sunulan yeni sentaks öğesi.
Burayı anladık mı?
Bu sadece tabii unique PTR sınıfıyla ilgili değil arkadaşlar.
Mesela set, multi-set, map gibi konteynerlerde de yine böyle yazabiliriz.
Mesela ama tabi C++20 desteği varsa.
Bir başka örnek.
Mesela bakınız bir set oluşturacağım.
Set'in int virgül arkadaşlar.
Decal type.
Yani en azından bunun legal olduğunu bilmeliyiz.
Int x int y.
Çünkü bunun avantaj sağlayabileceği bazı yerler var.
Diyelim ki return abs x küçük abs y.
noktalı bilmeliyiz.
Buradan buraya kadar Lambda ifadesi.
Ve ben Lambda ifadesini doğrudan decotype'ın operanda yaptım.
Böylece bu tür bilgisini elde ettim.
Arkadaşlar işte burada C++20'den önce örneğin Lambda ifadesini bu bağlamda kullansaydık.
Sentaks hatası olacaktı.
Mehmet Can Bey'in sorusuna gelelim.
Beyin fırtınası olunması ve standart kütüphanenin felsefesini anlamak için soruyorum.
Unique PTR sınıfının T yıldız türüne typecast operatör fonksiyonu overloadu olsaydı fena olmaz mıydı?
Bence fena olurdu.
Neden?
Çünkü bakın çok güzel bir soru aslında.
Arkadaşlar standart kütüphane değil sadece 3. parti kütüphanelerde tür dönüştürme operatörünü overload ederken son derece dikkatli.
Çünkü yanlışlıkla yapılan dönüşümler çok riskli.
Dolayısıyla T yıldız türüne örtülü dönüşüm sağlamak için tür dönüştürme operatörünü vermek yanlışlıkla yapılan dönüşümlere de neden olurdu.
Hiç olmaz demiyorum ama tür dönüştürme operatörünün verildiği yerlerde zaten bilinçli olarak onun kullanılması isteniyor.
Mesela geçenlerde bunun bir örneğini gördük.
Sayılı örneklerinden biri Mehmet Can Bey.
Hangisi?
Reference Rapper sınıfı.
Reference Rapper sınıfının operatör TRF, tür dönüştürme operatör fonksiyonu var.
Böylece ben Reference Rapper nesnesini doğrudan sarmaladığı nesneymiş gibi belirli bağlamlarda kullanabiliyorum.
O yüzden ben tercih etmezdim standart kütüphanede yine bu nedenle tercih etmemişim.
Arkadaşlar şimdi devam edelim.
Demek ki ben bir custom deleter kullanabilirim.
İlla kaynağın ne olması gerekmiyor?
Arkadaşlar Niv operatörlerinden biriyle oluşturulmuş dinamik ömürlü nesne olması gerekmiyor.
Burada bir yanlış anlamı olmasın.
Burada Lambda ifadesi kullanmak zorunda da değiliz.
Mesela bakın başka bir örnek.
İzleyin.
Çok tipik handle sistemi var.
Struct diyelim ki data.
Klasik ismimiz.
İki tane fonksiyonumuz var.
Data yıldız.
Create data.
Boot.
Bir de clean up fonksiyonumuz var.
Yani sonlandırma fonksiyonumuz.
İster clean up değil, ister destroy değil.
Data yıldız.
Bu belki de bir CO2'si.
Ama ben bunu unique BTR ile kullanmak istiyorum.
Mesela şöyle kullanmak istiyorum.
Arkadaşlar memori başlık dosyasını yine dahil edelim.
Bakın, bakın.
Madem create data, data yıldız döndürüyor.
O zaman
Unique BTR'ın
data açılımı
ama
ikinci bir template parametresine ihtiyacım var.
U, P, T, R
ve
create data.
Ama şimdi
buraya ne yazacağım?
Cevap
buraya
BTR
türünü
yazmam gerekiyor.
BTR türü olarak
bir namda ifadesi de oluşturabilirim ama
şuna ne dersiniz?
Struct
Data cleaner
void
Operatör
Arkadaşlar
fonksiyon çağrı
Data yıldız
ve
Clean up
P
Yani yukarıdaki clean up fonksiyonuna bunu gönderiyorum.
Böylece
buraya da ne yazıyorum?
Doğrudan
bu türü
Şimdi
iyi bakın
daha da iyi anlayacaksınız.
İşte bakın
böyle bir tür kullanmak yerine
ben bunu
ne de yapabilirdim?
Bir
local class da yapabilirdim.
Yavaş yavaş gidelim.
İşte bunu
local class
bu şekilde yapmak yerine
zaten bunun kendisi
bir
Factor class
işte burada
böyle bir sınıfı
derleyicinin yazması için de
şöyle yazıyorum
foto
F
arkadaşlar
D
C
eşittir
lambda ifadesi
sonuçta üretilen kod
neredeyse aynı.
Evet
fonksiyonun parametresi
arkadaşlar
Data yıldız
bakın
çok daha pratik oldu.
Öyle değil mi?
Şunları sileyim.
Clean up P
ama
şimdi
sadece ne değişecek?
Buraya
FDC'nin
türünü yazmam
gerekir.
Buraya
FDC'nin
türünü
yazmak için de
Decl type
FDC
yazıyorum.
Ya da
C++
desteği varsa
yine
başladığımız yere
geri döndük.
bunu aldığım
buraya koydum
ama
arkadaşlar
buraya koydum.
Şöyle yazalım.
Alamadım.
Şöyle tek satırı
alayım.
Boşluklarını
sonra alırım.
İşte bakın
şunu aldığım
Becl type
FDC
yerine
Unavaluated
komplexte
lambda
ifadesinin
kendisine
kullandım.
No except
ekleyebiliriz
tabi ama
no except
ekleyeceğim
yer
neresi?
Hatırlayın
lambda
ifadelerini
arkadaşlar
şurası
değil mi?
Eğer böyle
yazarsam
exception
throw etmediğini
gösteriyor.
eğer soru
şuysa
clean up
fonksiyonu
burada
exception
throw etmeme
garantisi
verdiği için
bunun bir
C apisi
olduğunu düşünüyoruz.
Zaten
C apisi
exception
throw
etmiyor
C'de
exception
and link
olmadığı için.
Efendim
sonra
biraz hızlanalım
artık.
Deleter
konusunu gördük.
Custom
Deleter
oluşturabiliriz.
Unique
PTR'ın
bir
Insurter
olduğunu da
öğrenmiştik.
Yani
örneğin
Mac
bu arada
Mac Unique'i de
hatırlayalım.
Mac Unique
Burada
bizim
yardımcı
sınıflarımız
vardı.
Onlardan birini
alalım.
Mesela
Person
arkadaşlar
basit bir sınıf
zaten göreceksiniz
şimdi.
Bakınız
Mac Unique'in
Person
açılımı
arkadaşlar
başlık dosyasını
dahil edelim.
Constructor'a
göndereceğimiz
argümanı
gönderelim.
Necati
Ergin
geri dönüş
değerini
Unique
PTR
nesnesinde
tutalım.
Ve şimdi
geçen derslerimizde
konuştuklarımızı
hatırlayalım.
D-referens
edebilirim.
Destructor'ı
benim nesnemi
delete edecek.
Unique
PTR'nin
fonksiyonlarını
hatırlayalım.
Arkadaşlar
get
adresi
get ediyor.
Get
deleter
get ediyor.
Operatör
bul
boş mu
dolu mu
sınamasını
yapıyor.
Operatör
içerik ve
D-referencing
fonksiyonları
Operatör
atama
fonksiyonumuz
var.
Release
mülkiyeti
bırakıyor ama
delete etmiyor.
Reset
adeta
atama
operatörü
gibi
arkadaşlar
eğer
argüman
göndermeden
çağırırsak
Null
PTR
göndermiş
oluyorduk.
Bir
heyyıldız
türünden
argümanla
çağırırsak
ne yapıyor?
yeni
olarak
eskisini
destroy ediyor.
Yeni
kaynağı
yeni kaynağın
kontrolünü
edinir.
Ve yine
swap
fonksiyonumuz
var.
Şimdi dikkat
arkadaşlar
mesela bu
kodda
burada
artık
person
nesnemiz
destroy
edilmiş
durumda
değil mi?
Çünkü
UTA'nın
scope'u
bittiği için.
evet
ama
person'ın
böyle bir
nesi
yokmuş
constructor
iki tane
parametreliymiş
o zaman
Necati
Ergin
isme
soy isme
ayrı
istiyormuş
federleyip
çalıştırıyorum
evet
bu noktada
destructörün
içinde bir yazı
olmadığı için
görmedik ama
nesnemiz
destroy
olmuş
durumda.
Arkadaşlar
ama benim
anlatmak istediğim
bu değildi.
Diyecektim ki
tekrar buraya
geri dönelim
Unique
PTR'nin
o
Stream
Insurter'ı
var.
Yani
şöyle
yazmak
bunu
geçen
dertimizde
konuşmuştuk
ama
bir daha
üstünden
geçelim.
Aslında
şöyle
yazmaya
eşdeğer.
Takip edebiliyor
muyuz?
Evet
sonuçta
get fonksiyonu
adresi döndürüyor
ama
delete
etmiyor.
UP
yazmakta
buradaki
Insurter'da
zaten
get fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
onu
Stream'e
veriyor.
Evet
bunu da
konuşmuştuk
arkadaşlar.
Şimdi
detaya
girip
ana
kritik noktaları
ihmal etmememiz
gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlar
aman
dikkat
Unique
PTR'nin
bize sağladığı
birinci
fayda
belki
kaynağın
hayatını
otomatik
olarak
kontrol
etmek
ve
exception
save de
sağlıyor
değil mi?
Yani
geçen
derste
verdiğimiz
örneği
hatırlayın.
Diyelim ki
burada bir
fonksiyon
var
void
bu
normal
ham
pointer
kullanmak
yerine
Unique
pointer
kullanırsak
mesela
make
unique
efendim
string
ya da
person
madem var
Ali
Han
Oscar
ve burada
bir takım
başka kodlar
var.
Örneğin
bar isimli
fonksiyonun
çağrılma
kodu
gibi
void
bar
arkadaşlar
şimdi artık
garanti altındayız.
Nasıl
exception
prove ederse
exception'ı
handle eden
koda gidecek.
Mesela
bakınız
diyelim ki
exception
burada handle
ediliyor.
Arkadaşlar
try
bu
ama
exception
göndermezse
de
ne yapacağız
arkadaşlar
zaten
scope'un sonunda
unique
ptr
nesnesi
destroy
olacak.
Yani
ya
stack
unwindingle
ya da
normal
yolda
scope'unun
bitmesiyle
buradaki
arkadaşlar
ismini
verelim
auto
up
lokal
unique ptr
nesnesinin
destractor'ı
çağrılacak.
Öyle değil mi?
Hatta
bakınız
ikinci senaryoyu da
görelim.
Bar'a
12 argümanını
gönderelim.
Bar'ın
intür'den bir
parametresi
olsun.
Diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
buraya gelen sayı
tek sayıysa
x mod 2
exception
throw
etsin.
Throw
scope
runtime
error
from
bar.
Şimdi
programın
akışına
bakın.
Ve
bu
person'ın
destractor'ında
yazalım.
destractor'ın
çağrıldığını
görelim.
Kill the
person.
See
out
arkadaşlar
efendim
zaten
görüyorsunuz
değil mi?
See
out
yıldız
this
so
see
out
yıldız
this
is
being
destroyed.
is
being
destroyed.
Oldu değil mi?
Evet.
Şimdi
bakın
destractor
çağrıldığında
bu yazının
standart
output'a
çıkması
lazım.
Eğer
yazmayı
becerebilirsek.
Derleyelim.
arkadaşlar
şurada
iost
stream
include
edeceğim.
Tamam.
Arkadaşlar
bakın şu anda
exception
throw
etmiyor.
Exception
throw
etmediği
için
programın
akışı
bu
noktaya
kadar
gelecek.
Burada
up
destroy
olacak.
Yani
up'nin
destractor'ı
çağıracak.
up'nin
destractor'ı
da
person
nesnesini
delete
edecek.
Önce
happy
pet'i
görelim.
Yani
exception
gönderilmediği
senaryoyu.
Alian
Bozkır'ın
ismini
böyle kötü
bir cümlede
kullanmak
istemiyorum.
Arkadaşlar
kendimi
feda
ediyorum.
Necati
Ergin.
Evet.
Necati
Ergin
is being
destroyed.
Ama
şimdi de
exception
gönderirsin.
Ve
stack
unbindingle
programın
akışı
catch
bloğuna
girmeden
otomatik
ömürlü
unique
ptr
nesnesi
stack
unbinding
sürecinde
destroy
olacak.
Ve
o da
destractor'ı da
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
gördüğünüz gibi
yine
delete
edecek.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
unique
ptr'nin
kullanıldığı
tipik bir
başka senaryo
sınıfın
veri elemanı
olması.
Çünkü
neden?
Bunu da
exception
antling
konusunda
görmüştük.
Mesela
şöyle bir
sınıf
olsaydı
class
my
private
arkadaşlar
yine
person'ı
kullanalım.
Burada
person
yıldız
mp
böyle bir
pointer
olsaydı
my
class
herhangi bir
sınıf.
Arkadaşlar
sınıfın
public
bölümünde de
şöyle bir
konstruktör
olsaydı
örneğin
people
konstruktör
ya da
const
st
string
name
ve
bakın
mp
new
arkadaşlar
person
name
surname
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz?
Eee
şimdi
bu
pointer
arkadaşlar
her türlü
riski
sunuyor
bize.
Mesela
konstruktör'ın
ana bloğu
içinde
bir
exception
prove
ederse
arkadaşlar
bizim
nesnemiz
delete
edilemeyecek
tipik olarak
şöyle bir
destruktör
olacak.
Arkadaşlar
my
class
ve
destruktör'da
mp'yi
delete
edecek.
Ama
şimdi
bunun
delete
edilmesi
için
my
class
sınıfının
destruktör'ının
çağrılması
gerekiyor.
Oysa
örneğin
konstruktör'ın
ana bloğu
içinde bir
exception
prove
ederse
dinamik
ömürlü
person
nesnesi
hayata
gelmiş
olacak.
Ama
my
class
nesnesi
hayata
gelmemiş
olduğu
için
my
class'ın
destruktör'a
çağrılmayacak.
Oysa
bunu ben
anlatmıştım
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
exception
handling
konusunda.
Oysa
burada
raw
pointer
kullanmak
yerine
sınıfın
veri
isterseniz
deneyin
bakınız
diyelim ki
konstruktör
exception
prove
throw
stood
runtime
error
arkadaşlar
my
class
exception
şimdi
my
class
sınıfı türünden
bir nesne
oluşturuyorum
my
class
me
necati
ergin
hatta
şöyle
bloğumuz
olsun
arkadaşlar
burası
try
bloğu
içinde
olsa
dahi
evet
konstruktör'dan gönderilen
exception'i yakalıyorum
başka bir eksiklik
yoksa
izleyin
arkadaşlar
exception
kod
my
class
exception
ama
burada
person nesnesi
oluştu mu
Alihan
evet
çünkü
programın akışı
konstruktör'ın
ana bloğuna
girdi
ee
dinamik ömürlü nesne
dirilt edildi mi
hayır
peki neden
çünkü
destruktör çağrılmadı
ama
şimdi kodu
değiştirelim
bunu
unique
ptr
yapalım
stut
unique
ptr'ın
person
açılımı
arkadaşlar
mp
ismi yine
olarak
kalsın
mp
arkadaşlar
near
destruktör'ı
artık
derlejin
yazmasına
bir
engel
yok
evet
pro
student
time
error
mp
yi de
gördüğünüz gibi
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin adresiyle
initialize
ettim
bir eksik kaldı
mı
şimdi bakın
aradaki
tek fark
hand pointer
kullanmak yerine
sınıfın
veri elemanı
olarak
arkadaşlar
unique
ptr
kullandım
gördüğünüz gibi
nesne
destroy oldu
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
biraz daha
yolumuz var
unique ptr'la
ilgili
ondan sonra da
okdemelen
ikinci dersi itibariyle
şef ptr sınıfına
geçeceğiz
alihan
bozkır'ın
sorusu
smart pointer
sınıflarının
konstraktörleri
not
raw
garanti
diyebilir
miyiz
soruyu tam
anlayamadım
smart pointer
sınıflarının
konstraktörleri
hayır
arkadaşlar
böyle bir şey
söylemedim
smart pointer
sınıfının
konstraktörü
zaten bakın
smart pointer
sınıfının
konstraktörü
not raw
garanti
veriyor mu
cevabı
hayır
çünkü
zaten
konstraktör
şunlar
izleyin
ya default
constructor
default
constructor'ın
no accept
not raw
garantisi
vermesinde
bir problem
yok
arkadaşlar
ama
bakınız
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
adresiyle
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
adresiyle
başlatan
onun da
bir düşünelim
exception
safe
olmasında
t yıldız
parametrelinin
bir
ne yok
diyelim
bir engel
yok
neden
çünkü bakın
new person
diyelim ki
böyle bir
konstraktör
kullandım
bu arada
tekrar söylüyorum
bakın
unique ptr'nin
iki tane
konstraktörü var
biri
default
konstraktör
tabi copy
move
konstraktör'dan
bahsetmiyorum
bir de
move
konstraktörü
var
biri de
t yıldız
parametreli
konstraktör
şimdi
bu t yıldız
parametreli
konstraktör
aynı
akbaş
öyle değil mi
unique ptr'e
first
açılımı
up
ne yapıyor
unique ptr'nin
ayağının
sorusu
değil mi
unique ptr
ama
sorunuz
güzel
fakat
sorunuz
bir önceki
konuyla
doğrudan
ilişkili
değil
siz şunu
sordunuz
yanlış
anlamadı
sen
unique ptr'nin
konstraktörü
exception
göndermeme
garantisi
veriyor mu
arkadaşlar
exception
göndermeme
garantisi
vermesinde
hiç bir
engel yok
çünkü
tek yaptığı
buradan aldığı
adreste
pointer değişkeni
initialize
etmek
yani kendisi
bu konstraktör
kendi içinde
exception
gönderme
ihtimali olan
bir kod
var mı
yok
yanlış anlaşılmasın
arkadaşlar
burada
person
nesnesini
dinamik olarak
oluştururken
exception
trove edilirse
zaten
unique ptr
sınıfının
konstraktörü
çağrılmayacak
zaten
buradan
programın
akışı
handler
koda
gidecek
evet
dolayısıyla
konstraktörün
exception
göndermeme
garantisine
sahip olmasında
bir engel
yok
arkadaşlar
şimdi
ilginç bir şey
söyleyeceğim
lütfen
buraya
dikkat
en önemli
noktalardan
biri
biz
dinamik
ömürlü
nesneleri
oluşturmak
için
bazı
niv
ifadelerini
kullanıyoruz
demiştik
bunlardan
bir tanesi
de
array
nildi
arkadaşlar
eğer şöyle
bir kod
yazarsam
bakınız
diyelim ki
bu sefer
arkadaşlar
date'i
kullanayım
örneğin
ve
unique ptr'nin
include date
nokta
h
unique ptr'nin
date
açılımı
unique ptr'nin
date
açılımı
up
ve
new
date
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
n
ismi de
düzeltelim
ve n
değişkenimizi
tanımlayalım
sabırlı bir şekilde
beni
beklerseniz
hatta
bakın
size t
n
see out
kaç
nesne
programın çalışma zamanında belli olduğunu göstermek istiyorum
see in
n
ve
array
new
operatörünü kullanarak
n elemanlı bir
date
dizisi oluşturuyorum
ama
onun
o adresi
unique ptr
nesnesini
initialize
etmek için
construct etmek için
kullanıyorum
yani
unique ptr'nin t yıldız parametreli
constructorına
burada elde edilen
dynamic date
dizisinin
adresini veriyorum
şimdi buradaki
problemin ne olduğunu
anlayabiliyor musunuz
birden fazla
problem var
şimdi buradaki problemleri
tek tek anlamanızı istiyorum
ki asla böyle bir yapı
kullanmayacağız
problemlerden biri
unique ptr'nin
bestractor'ı
ne yapıyor
alihan ve diğer
arkadaşlarım
cevap
şu anda
default delete'i
kullandığına göre
bravo
default delete'i
kullandığına göre
arkadaşlar
sarmaladığı
adresi
delete ediyor
öyle değil mi
bravo
kesinlikle
nereye gelmek istediğimi
Yiğit hemen söyledi
oysa burada
delete köşeli
parantez gerekiyor
dolayısıyla
izleyiniz
buraya geldiğim zaman
programın akışı
array
nivle
elde edilmiş
dynamic
date
dizisini
delete etmek için
array
delete'i
kullanmak yerine
yalın
delete'i
kullandığımı
için
tanımsız davranış
söz konusu
öyle değil mi
evet
yani bir kere burada
kesinlikle
tanımsız davranış var
tanımsız davranış varsa
işimiz bitti
tanımsız davranışın
olması
runtime'da bunu
gözleyebileceğim
anlamına
gelmiyor
arkadaşlar ki
gördüğünüz gibi
gözleye de
bildim
anormali olduğu
programın
çalışma biçiminden
belli
diyelim ki
buradaki problemi
şöyle
engellemeye
çalıştım
ki
engelleyebilirim
ne kullanarak
custom
delete'i
kullanarak
şimdi bakın
bravo
arkadaşlar
tanımsız davranış var mı
sadece soruya cevap
vermeye çalışın
tanımsız davranış var mı
cevap yok
ama şimdi de
başka bir problem var
nedir problem
anlatacağım
arkadaşlar
dinamik diziyi
handle edecek bir
interfejse
sahip değiliz
mesela
biz bu durumda
tıpkı normal
pointer olsaydı
pointer bir diziyi
gösterdiğinde
köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonuyla
arkadaşlar
ya da köşeli parantez
operatörüyle fonksiyonuyla
demeyelim de
yani
UP gerçek pointer
olsaydı
böyle bir ifadeyle
örneğin
dinamik dizideki
bait nesnelerinden
üçüncüsüne
erişebilirdim
değil mi
evet
ama
böyle bir
interfej yok
yani
custom
delete'i
kullansam
dahi
şöyle
komik
kodlar
yazmam
gerekiyor
komik ve
rahatsız edeceğim
nasıl
arkadaşlar
gideceğim
UP'nin
get fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
get fonksiyonu
sarmalanan adresi
döndürdüğüne göre
get fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş değerini
köşeli parantez
operatörün
operatöründe
yapacağım
ama bunun yerine
çok daha iyi bir
çözüm var
tahmin edin
arkadaşlar
dizi türleri
için
partial specialization
var
yani
unique
ptr
sınıfı
zaten
bunu
bize
kendisi
sunuyor
yani
böyle bir
kod yazmak
yerine
doğrudan
şöyle bir
kod yazabiliyoruz
unique
ptr'ın
buraya dikkat
date
array
açılımı
unique
ptr'ın
nasıl
date array
açılımı
varsa
yani
bu bir
partial
specialization
ise
default
delete'in
de
bir
partial
specialization
var
arkadaşlar
default
delete'e
geri dönelim mi
şimdi
ben yazayım
ama tabi
orijinalini
kullanacağım
şöyle bir
partial
specialization
olduğunu
düşünün
gerçekten
böyle
template
type name
t
arkadaşlar
izleyin
tut
default
delete'in
bunu bırakmayacağım
kodda
struct
default
delete'in
arkadaşlar
ne açılımı
p köşeli parantez
açılımı
böyle bir
partial
specialization
var
tahmin edin
yiğit
bu
partial
specialization'ın
operatör
fonksiyon
çağrı
fonksiyonu
yine t
yıldız
parametreli
olması
gerektiği
gibi
ama
bu kez
bunun kodu
nasıl
yazılmış
delete
köşeli
parantez
p
anladık
mı
dolayısıyla
unique
ptr'nin
array
specialization'ı
yani
partial
specialization
bunun
destraktör'ı
arkadaşlar
bunun
default template
argümanı
default delete'in
bu seferde
ne açılımı
date köşeli
parantez
açılımı
o da
delete
array delete'i
kullanıyor
bu da şu
demek
gerçekten
nadir
ya da
seyrek olsa
seyrek ya da
nadir de olsa
bir
unique ptr
nesnesine
dinamik bir dizinin
hayatını
kontrol etmek
için
kullanırsanız
o zaman
tek yapmanız
gereken
unique ptr'nin
array açılımını
kullanmak
ama buradan
gelen bir
fayda daha
var
bakın
up
arkadaşlar
izleyin
n
new
neydi
date
köşeli
parantez
n
arkadaşlar
önce
gerçekten
bir problem
olmadığını
görelim
tıpkı
az önce
custom
delete'i
yazdığımız
örnekte
olduğu gibi
orada nasıl
bir problem
yoksa
burada da
bir problem
yok
ama
hatırlayınız
partial
specialization
ya da
full specialization
oluşturursam
bir sınıfa
onun
interfejsi
primary
template'le
aynı
olmak
zorunda
mı
cevap
hayır
kaldı ki
primary template
incomplete
type
bile olabilir
işte
burada da
böyle
bakın
az önce
hatta
izleyin
10 kez
dönen bir
döngüde
az önce
unique ptr
nesnesini
köşeli
parantez
operatörünün
subscript
operanda
yaptığımda
syntax
hatası
olmuştu
ama
bakın
şimdi
syntax
hatası
yok
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
buradaki
interfejste
gördüğümüz gibi
operatör köşeli
parantez
var
ama
burada da
yıldız
yok
espriyi
görüyor musunuz
bakın
yıldız
upe
yani
asterisk
dereferencing
operatörü
yok
sadece
dereferencing
operatörü
olarak
subscript
operatörü
var
hatta bunu
deneyelim
bakın
siyahat
up köşeli
parantez
i
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
tabi şu anda
bütün
date nesnelerimiz
default
construct edildiği
için
default
construct edilmiş
date nesnesinin
de değeri
hatırlayın
1-1
olduğu için
hepsi
1-1
değerinde
date nesnelerinin
kaç nesne
ve bir problem
olmadığını
arkadaşlar
göreceksiniz
değil mi
eğer
burada
kullandığım
köşeli parantez
açılımıysa
yani
delete
operatörü de
burada
unique
ptr'nin
destructörü de
burada ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
default
delete'in
köşeli parantez
açılımını
template argümanı
olarak alıyor
bravo çağırın
peki
o zaman
kaldığımız yerden
şimdi devam edelim
en son ne dedik
bir de
array
specialization'ı
var
unique ptr
sınıfının
eğer
dinamik dizinin
hayatını
kontrol etmemiz
gerekirse
array specialization'ı
kullanıyoruz
array specialization'ın
interfazinde
içerik operatör
fonksiyonu
yok
sadece
index
operatör
subscript
fonksiyonumuz var
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bir de
runtime
polimorfizmine
gelelim
nasıl
normal
bir pointer
taban sınıf
türünden
nesnenin
adresini
tutuyorsa
ve ben
o pointer
vasıtasıyla
sınıfın
bir sanal
fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaptığımda
arkadaşlar
burada
virtual dispatch
gerçekleşiyorsa
unique ptr
sınıfı
türünden
nesneyle
virtual dispatch
yapmanızda
hiçbir sakınca
yok ki
neden
bakınız
zaten
bunu
açıklamaya
bile
gerek yok
ama
ben yine
de
açıklayacağım
şu bizim
kar sınıfı
lütfen
dikkatli izleyin
arkadaşlar
şunlar
kar sınıfının
sanal
fonksiyonları
hatırladınız mı
böyle bir
sınıfımız vardı
hatta
bir de
test kodu
oluşturmak
amaçlı
create random
car
isimli
bir fonksiyonumuz
vardı
burada
dikkat ederseniz
create random
car
sınıfı
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
kar pointer
arkadaşlar
böyle bir
kullanım
son derece
tehlikeli
yine başladığımız
yere
geri dönüyoruz
bakın şimdi
kar başlık
dosyasını
dahil ettim
ve
create random
car
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
geri dönüş
değerini
bir pointer
da sakladım
ve virtual
dispatch'ten
istifade
ettim
örneğin
arkadaşlar
pay
ok
start
pay ok
run
stop
işim bittiğinde
delete ettim
şimdi yine
delete etmek
zorundayım
değil mi
kesinlikle
destructorın da
virtual olduğunu
hatırlayalım
ne fark etti
zaten
bütün
varlık
nedeni
demeyelim de
hemen hemen
varlık
nedeninin
arkadaşlar
birinci
sebebi
bu da kötü
bir cümle
oldu
birinci varlık
nedeni
nedeninin
sebebi
birinci varlık
nedeni
kontrol etti
hayatını kontrol
ettiği
nesneyi
işe bittiğinde
destroy
edebilmesi
ama burada
tekrar delete
ediyorum
o zaman
burada da
unique
ptr
sınıfını
kullanabilir
miyim
arkadaşlar
kesinlikle
bakınız
madem
create random
karın
geri dönüş
değeri
bir
kar yıldız
yani
kar
pointları
o zaman
bu adresi
kim de
sarmalayabilirim
unique ptr
nin kar
açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
buradaki
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
hayatını
kontrol edebilir
deneyelim
bakınız
see out
main
başladı
şimdi
herkes
dikkatli
izliyor
geri dönüş
değerini
unique
ptr
in
par
açılımı
türünden
değişkende
değişkene
konser
hak
etmek
için
kullandım
herkes
dikkatli
izliyor
arkadaşlar
ben
o
koperatörünü
kullandığım
zaman
aslında
o koperatörü
sarmaladığı
adresi
kullanıyor
değil mi
öyle değil mi
zaten bu
fonksiyon
project
over load
edilmiş
ee
bu durumda
biz
aslında
start
fonksiyonunu
bir
kar
nesnesinin
adresiyle
çağırıyoruz
burada da
virtual dispatch
tabii ki
devreye giriyor
yani
unique
pointer
nesnesiyle
sınıfın
sanal fonksiyonlarını
çağırdığınızda
virtual dispatchin
devreye
girmesinde
herhangi bir
renginin
olmadığını
söylemek
istiyorum
değil mi
evet
bunu zaten
açıklamaya bile
gerek yok
isterseniz
bakın
ama sadece
ne fark etti
programın akışı
18. satıra
geldiğinde
unique
ptr nesnesinin
hayatı bitecek
unique
ptr nesnesi
için
destructor
çağrılacak
çağrılan
destructor da
pointerı
delete
edecek
isterseniz
bakın
arkadaşlar
ve
virtual dispatchin
devreye
girdiğini
görüyorsunuz
hatta
bakın
see out
yıldız
up
stop
see out
burada
virtual print
denilen
idiomu
kullanmıştık
o konuyu
hatırlarsanız
hatta
bunu
bir döngü
içinde
yapalım
yazalım
döngü
döngün
her türünde
bir
yeni
unique
ptr nesnesi
oluşturulacak
ve
unique
ptr nesnesinin
destructor
döngünün
ana
bloğunun
sonunda
çağrılacak
destructor
da
delete
edecek
sarmaladığı
pointerı
şuraya da
bir
get card
charge
koyalım
ve derleyip
çalıştıralım
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
tabi
ben bu konuyu
anlattığımda
runtime
polymortizme
konusunu
anlattığımda
henüz
unique
ptr'yi
anlatmamıştım
zaten
böyle bir
fonksiyonu
gerçekten
yazsaydım
geri dönüş
değerini
kar yıldız
yapmak
yerine
unique
ptr
yapardım
yani fonksiyonu
da böyle
yazardım
izleyin
create
random
car
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş
değeri
kar yıldız
değil
suit
unique
ptr
kar
açılımı
tabi
bu durumda
fonksiyonun
return
deyimlerinde
ifadesi
böyle
olamaz
çünkü
hatırlayın
t yıldızdan
unique
ptr'a
örtülü
dönüşüm
yok
ya burada
bravo
mehmetcan bey
make unique
i çağıracağım
yani şöyle
olacak
arkadaşlar
make
unique
in
mercedes
açılımı
evet
şöyle
isterseniz
kodu
tekrar
düzenleyelim
bunu
1 yapalım
2 yapalım
3 yapalım
4 yapalım
ve
şuraları da
değiştirelim
arkadaşlar
fiyat
reno
alttakileri
sileceğim
volvo
volvo xj90
Audi ve
Opel
Audi
ve
Opel
şunları
sileyim
bakın
fonksiyonu
bu hale getirdik
şimdi
evet
artık
doğrudan
şöyle yazabilirim
auto
u p
arkadaşlar
eşittir
create
random
par
taşıma
semantiği
zaten
devreye
girecek
ve
burada da
döngünler
turunda
nesnenin
hayatı
bittiğinde
unique
ptr
nesnesi
içinde
destraktör
çağrılacak
artık
her zamanki
hikayeyi
tekrar etmiyorum
evet
bakın
Opel
fiyat
arkadaşlar
bu şekilde
tabi benim
kodda
başka
eksiklik
varsa
daha önceden
gelen
onu bilmiyorum
anlaşıldı
değil mi
kod
kaldırılım
bir de
vardı
o yüzden
o değilse
bizimki
olsun
bir tane daha
varmış
demek ki
evet
herhangi bir şekilde
bir problem olmadığını
görüyoruz
peki
şimdi
unique ptr ile ilgili
bir
küçük
ama önemli
nokta daha var
belki son alt başlığımız
diyebiliriz
şimdilik
unique ptr ile ilgili
bu arada
bu soruyu da
sormakta fayda var
acaba
acaba şöyle bir
atama
legal mi
elimizde
unique ptr'nin
kar açılımı
türünden
bir ptr var
ve
örneğin şöyle bir şey
yazabilir miyiz
arkadaşlar
up
kar
hatırlayın
reset fonksiyonumuz
vardı
a
reset fonksiyonuna
new
audi
herhangi bir şekilde
tabire
ben
neden
çünkü zaten
buradaki
reset fonksiyonu
aldığı adresi
kime yerleştiriyor
sarmaladığı
pointer'a
dolayısıyla
taban sınıf türünden
pointer'a
türemi sınıf
nesnesi
adresi
atanabildiğine göre
problem yok
aynısı
konstruktör ile de
konstruktör için de
geçerli
mesela şöyle
yazabilir miyim
new
audi
zaten
leming örnekte
bunu
yazmıştık
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
unique ptr'nin
kullanıldığı
3-4 tane
tipik senaryoyu
tekrar bir üstünden
geçmek istiyorum
arkadaşlar
bir
bir fonksiyonun
parametresi
unique ptr
olabilir
ve bu fonksiyonu
çağıran koddan
bir nesnenin
mülkiyetini
bir
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
ya da bir kaynağı
mülkiyetini
alabilir
mesela şöyle bir fonksiyon
olsa
void
fun
arkadaşlar
yine
person
başlık
dosyasını
dahil edelim
stud
unique ptr'nin
person
açılımı
up
şimdi burayı
çok dikkatli
izleyelim
bu durumda
ben bu fonksiyona
bir unique ptr
sağ taraf
değeri olan
bir unique ptr
nesnesiyle
çağrı yapabilirim
ama
l-value
unique ptr
nesnesiyle
çağrı yapamam
yani elimde
şöyle bir unique ptr
nesnesi olsun
o da
up
eşittir
arkadaşlar
make unique
person
her dar
karaduman
şimdi fonksiyonu
şöyle çağırsam
func
up
syntax hatası
olacak
çünkü
kopyalamaya
karşı kapalı
ama fonksiyonu
böyle çağırabilirim
stud move
up
ya da bu fonksiyonu
lütfen
her bir maddeye
dikkat
böyle çağırabildiğim
gibi
doğrudan
bir
r-value
expression'la da
çağırabilirim
mesela bu bir
x-value
değil mi
dolayısıyla
r-value
fonksiyonu
böyle de
çağırabilirdim
öyle değil mi
ya da fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
şöyle de
çağırabilirdim
şurası
silinmesin
evet
ya da fonksiyonu
şöyle de
çağırabilirdim
punk
geçişi nesne
ifadesi
unique
ptr'nin
person
açılımı
türünden
arkadaşlar
bir
geçici
nesne
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
unique ptr'nin
person
açılımı
türünden
şunları
yorum
satırına
alayım
evet
person
açılımı
böyle bir
konstruktörü
vardı
değil mi
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
evet
bakın bunların
hepsi
ne olacak
arkadaşlar
level olacak
bakalım
altın
niye
çiziyormuş
evet
çünkü
person
başlık
dosyasında
bakalım
konstruktörü
stud string
person'un
böyle bir
konstruktörü
varmış
evet
unique ptr'nin
tabi
niv
ifadesini
kullanmamışım
niv
person
yazdım
zannediyorum
şimdi yazdım
tamam
bakın bunların
hepsi
arkadaşlar
sonuçta
legal
önemli olan
rvalue olması
değil mi
yani
tekrar edelim
elimde
isimlendirilmiş
bir unique ptr
nesnesi
olabilir
onu
mu cast
yapıp
rvalue'ya
dönüştürebilirim
make unique
ya da benzer bir
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
unique ptr'dir
arkadaşlar
bu sağ taraf
değeridir
bu ifade
rvalue'dur
dolayısıyla
argüman olarak
gönderebilirim
ya da
bir geçici
nesne
oluşturma
ifadesi
unique ptr'nin
person
açılımı
new
person
şu parantezleri
düzgün yazarsak
olacak
hepsinin parantez
dolanın
arkadaşlar
şu
person
constructor
için
bu da
küme parantezi
unique ptr
nesnesi için
bu da fonksiyonun
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörünün
parantezi
hepsi geçerli
şimdi burada bir şeye
dikkat
burası biraz
zorlayacak
bizi
böyle fonksiyonlara
sync deniyor
yani
sync şu demek
siz
nesneyi veriyorsunuz
nesnenin
muhtemelen
hayata başlatan
sizsiniz
sizlerken fonksiyonu
çağıran koddan
bahsediyorum
fakat
bu fonksiyonun
çağrılmasından
sonra
nesnenin
hayatı
bitiyor
yani bu fonksiyon
gönderdiğiniz
nesne
bu fonksiyonun
içinde
son buluyor
hayatı bitiyor
arkadaşlar
mesela bakınız
gerçekten
pankı böyle
çağıralım
ve
şuraya da
main devam ediyor
yazısını
çıkartalım
main
devam ediyor
böylece
unique ptr
nesnemiz
taşındı
unique ptr
nesnemiz
taşındığı
için
arkadaşlar
mülkiyet
buna geçti
buradaki
up
boşa çıktı
ve main
devam ediyor
arkadaşlar
burada
parametre değişkeninin
hayatı bittiğinde
bizim dinamik ömürlü
nesnede
ne olmuş olacak
delete edilmiş olacak
dolayısıyla
destruktörü çalışacak
isterseniz şuraya
getkar çağrılsın
koyarak
bunu
size gösterelim
izleyin
böyle fonksiyonlara
ne deniyormuş
arkadaşlar
sync
deniyormuş
arkadaşlar
ikinci model
ikinci tipik senaryo
fabrika fonksiyonu
sync
kadar
belki daha da yaygın
olan fabrika fonksiyonu
fabrika fonksiyonu
da şöyle
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri
unique ptr
her çağrına
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesne
veriyor
mesela
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir fonksiyon
olsaydı
fu
fu'nun geri dönüş
değeri
iki tane parametre
ya da şöyle olsun
diyelim ki
create person
ya da make person
daha çok yapışıyor
c++
make person
const
stut
string
ref
name
const
stut
string
ref
surname
ama fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değerine bakın
return
arkadaşlar
stut
unique
ptr
ya da make unique
ikisi de olur
değil mi
stut
make unique
person
name
surname
arkadaşlar
make unique
person
açılımı
name
surname
böylece
bu fonksiyonu
çağıran koda
burada oluşturulan
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
kontrol eden
unique ptr
nesnesini
taşımış oluyoruz
artık şöyle
kullanabiliriz
değil mi
o
uvp
eşittir
arkadaşlar
make person
argüman olarak
yine aynı
argümanları
geçelim
ve
siyahat
yıldız
uvp
uvp nesnesinin
hayatı
bittiğinde
yine
destroy olacak
böyle
fabrika fonksiyonları
çok sık
karşımıza çıkıyor
işte az önce
yazdığımız
create
kar fonksiyonu
böyle bir fabrika
fonksiyonuydu
hocam dönüş
değeri
otoref
olsaydı
arkadaşlar dönüş
değeri
otoref
olsaydı
bu durumda
siz
yerel bir
nesneye
referans dönmüş
olurdunuz
geçir bir
nesneye
ya da yerel
referans
dönmek
tanımsız
davranış
olurdu
onun
unique
ptr
olup olmamasıyla
bir alakası
yok
anlaşıldı mı
şaharı
plus my class
şimdi siz
bana cevap
verin
my class
ref
arkadaşlar
foo
return
my class
bu kod
doğru mu
çağrı
söyleyin
yanlış
çünkü
sen taks hatası
öncelikle
neden
çünkü bu
r value
bu ise
referans
buraya kadar
tamam mı
peki
şimdi
soru
my class
me
return me
bu kod
legal mi
legal
ama
tanımsız
davranışa
olacak
bravo
Osman bey
anlaşıldı
değil mi
ama
derleyiciler
bunu
kolaylıkla
yakalıyor
artık
mesela
gerçekten
böyle bir
kod
yazsaydım
muhtemelen
temel
uyarı
switchlerinde
derleyicinin
bir lojik uyarı
mesajını
görecektim
görmedim ama
belki uyarı
ayarları ile
ilgili olabilir
biz şimdi
konumuza geri dönelim
ve
fabrika
modelinde
kalmıştık
ikinci tipi
kullanım
bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
arkadaşlar
unique ptr
olması
ve fonksiyonun
bir unique ptr
döndürmesi
böylece
unique ptr
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesne
oluşturuyor
ya da bir
kaynak oluşturuyor
kaynağı
fonksiyonu
çağırana
taşımış
oluyorsunuz
böylece
kim delete
edecek
problemi
ortadan
kalkıyor
şimdi
burada çok
sorulan
bir soru var
hemen
o soruya
da cevap
verelim
hadi
otoyu özellikle
kullanmıyorum
daha iyi
anlaşılsın
diye
studionic ptr
n'in
person
açılımı
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
diyelim
şimdi
fonksiyonu
böyle
yazarsak
yani
bir fabrika
fonksiyonunu
böyle yazarsak
çağıran
kodu
eksklusif
ownership
stratejisine
mahkum
etmiş
olmuyor
muyuz
ya
çağıran
kod
oluşturduğu
unique ptr
nesnesini
birden fazla
pointerla
kullanmak
istiyorsak
arkadaşlar
işte bu nedenle
ilerleyen dakikalarda
shared ptr
sınıfına
geldiğimizde
şunu göreceğiz
shared ptr
sınıfının da
unique ptr
parametreli
daha doğrusu
unique ptr
sağ taraf
referans
parametreli
bir
konstruktör
var
yani
her ne kadar
ilk bakışta
bu
fonksiyon
çağıran
kodu
eksklusif
ownership
stratejisine
zorluyor
gibi
görünse de
böyle değil
isterseniz
göstereyim
bakınız
shared ptr
person
açılımı
s ptr
arkadaşlar
make
person
ali
aksoy
bunu büyük
farkla
yazmışım
evet
bu kodun
level olmasının
nedenini
ikinci
derste
shared ptr
sınıfına
geldiğimizde
göreceğiz
shared ptr
sınıfının
unique ptr
ref ref
parametreli
yani
parametresi
unique ptr
sağ taraf
referansı
olan
bir
konstruktör
var
bu da
şu anlama
geliyor
eğer siz
bir fonksiyonun
bu örnekte
olduğu gibi
geri dönüş
değerini
bir
unique ptr
specialization
yaparsanız
bu fabrika
fonksiyonunu
çağıran
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeriyle
bir
unique ptr
nesnesini
initialize
ederse
tek sahiplik
ilkesiyle
kullanmış
olacak
ama bu
fonksiyona
yapılan
çağrıyı
bir
shared ptr
nesnesini
initialize
etmek için
oluşturmak için
kullanırsa
fonksiyon
çağrı
ifadesini
o zaman da
paylaşımlı
olarak
kullanacak
burası
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
bir de
üçüncü
bir modelimiz
var
bu
modele de
ingilizce
biraz daha az
kullanılıyor ama
pass through
diyorlar
da şöyle
siz
fonksiyonda
unique ptr
nesnesini
taşıyorsunuz
ama fonksiyonda
unique ptr
nesnesini
arkadaşlar
size
geri dönüş
değeriyle
yine
size aktarıyor
yani
örneğin şöyle
olsaydı
bakın bakın
bu sefer daha kolay
yazım için
using person ptr
eşittir
stud
unique ptr'nin
person açılımı
öyle bir fonksiyon ki
parametresi
person ptr
geri dönüş
değeri de
person ptr
yani
unique ptr'nin
person açılımı
örneğin
fonksiyon
aldığı nesneyle ilgili
bir takım işlemler
yaptı
pok
set name
mustafa
ama
aynı nesneyi
return etti
return p
tabi
lvalue expression
olmasına rağmen
lvalue to
xvalue
transformation ile
yine bu
geçerli olacak
hatırlıyorsunuz
otomatik ömürlü
nesne olduğu için
şimdi ben
bu fonksiyonu
şöyle çağırsam
auto
up
eşittir
arkadaşlar
mechanic
person
evet
ahmet
karabayır
up
eşittir
bu
stud
move
up
fonksiyonu çağıran koddan
fonksiyona taşındı
unique ptr nesnesi
fakat fonksiyonundan da
aynı unique ptr nesnesine
tekrar taşıdım
cout
yıldız
up
ve
nesnemiz henüz
destroy olmadı
onu göstermek için
burada durduralım
ve destructorın
henüz çağrılmadığını
ama getgar çağrısından sonra
destructorın
çağrıldığını
göreceğiz
evet
şurayı düzeltelim
başka nerede eksiklik var
evet
çalıştıralım
bakın
ahmet karabayır
musafa karabayır
henüz nesnemiz
delete edilmedi
şimdi delete edildi
girelim
son alt başlığımıza
unique ptr ile ilgili
şimdilik son alt başlığımız
arkadaşlar
konteynerlarda tutmakta
hiçbir engel yok
geçen dersine biraz
değinmiştik ama
şu kalsın
bakın bir örnek
using
person ptr
eşittir
stud unique ptr in person
specializationı
o zaman örneğin
ve gör başlık dosyasını
dahil edelim
ve
vektörün
person ptr
açılımı
pvek
şimdi bu vektör
unique ptr nesneleri
tutacak
arkadaşlar
pvek
reserve
ister
sağ taraf
referans parametreli
pushback
fonksiyonunu
çağırın
örneğin pvek
pushback
makunic
bakın burada kafanız karışacak mı
person
arkadaşlar
ahmet
delibaş
pushback'in
parametresi
iki tane pushback
vardı
biri
const trf parametreli
biri trf ref parametreli
burada trf ref parametreli
çağrıldı
öyle değil mi
ya da şöyle
yazabilir miyim
bakınız
and place back
bu durumda
benim argüman
hep
argüman olarak
unique ptr'nin
constrack tırına
gönderecek
argümanları
geçmem lazım
o zaman örneğin şöyle
yazabilirim
new person
arkadaşlar
süheyla
erdinç
hatta
nutil itibarşılık dosyasını
dahil edelim
yine bakın mesela
pushback
hatta şöyle
yazalım
8 kez
dönen bir döngü
olsun
döngünler
türüldü
pvek
pushback
make person
deminki make person
fonksiyonu
make person
şimdilik
auto return type
kullanayım
arkadaşlar
return
make unique
person
random
name
hatta
geri dönüşleri
auto olmasın
person
ptr olsun
zaten
türeş
ismi
stut
make
unique
person
açılımı
random
name
surname
böyle
fonksiyonlarımız
vardır
nutil iti
başlık dosyasında
evet
şimdi pushback
make person
opsiyonun geri dönüş
değeri
unique ptr
olduğu için
sağ taraf
değeri
pushback'in de
rvalue
referans
parametreli bir
constructor olduğu için
bir overload
olduğu için
bir problem
çıkmayacak
değil mi?
peki
şimdi
buraya kadar
derleyelim
konteynerı dolaşırken
yalnız dikkatli olmam
gerekiyor
şöyle yazamam artık
for
auto
up
pebek
neden yazamam?
çünkü burada bir
kopyalama var
oysa
kopyalamaya karşı
kapalı
ya şöyle yazacağım
arkadaşlar
konsole
olmamasına
yapacağım
zavallı
ya da
universal
referans
kullanacağım
ben şimdilik
el
value
referans
kullanayım
ve
arkadaşlar
see out
yıldız
up
şimdi
bir şey
dikkat
pump pointer
tutsaydım
delete
etmek
benim
sorumluluğumda
olacaktı
oysa
şimdi
vektör
nesnesinin
hayatı
bittiğinde
vektör
nesnesi
tuttuğu
nesnelerin
yani
kapta tutulan
nesnelerin
destructorlarını
çağıracak
eunic
ptr'lerin
destructor'ı
çağrıldığında
da
onlar da
oluşturulmuş
dinamik ömürlü
person nesnelerini
delete edecek
yani
programın
akışı
buraya gelene
kadar
henüz
person
nesneleri
destroy
olmuş
değil
destruct
edilmiş
değil
ama
burada
hatta
şöyle
yapalım
bunu da
bir blok
içine
alalım
arkadaşlar
ve
main
devam
şu
get car
çağrısını
buraya
koyalım
buraya da
main
devam ediyor
yazısını
çıkartalım
vektör
sınıfının
nesnesinin
construct
struktör'ı
buraya
geldiğinde
programın
akışı
çağrılacak
destraktör
elemanların
vektörde
tutulan
nesnelerin
destraktör'larını
çağıracak
ve
arkadaşlar
onlar da
unique
better'in
destraktör'ları
dinamik ömürlü
nesneleri
delete edecek
derliyorum
ve
çalıştırıyorum
bakın
ahmet gelibaş
müslüm
yersiz
adlan ecevit
vesaire
şimdi
buraya geldiğinde
destraktör'lar
çağrıldı
ve
arkadaşlar
eğer böyle bir
araç olmasaydı
biz
vektörün
person
yıldız
açılımını
kullanacaktık
öyle bir
konteynerı
kullanmak çok
zor
çünkü
a
konteynerı
nesnesi
destroy
edildiğinde
artık
iş işten
geçmiş oluyor
değil mi
bizim kendimizin
delete
etmesi
gerekiyor
ayrıca
bu
konteynerden
bir
öve
sildiğimizde
bakın
eğer
hatta
onu da
aynı örnek
üstünde
gösterelim
mesela
bakınız
etkar çağrısı
kalsın
burada
şöyle bir
kod yazayım
pevek
erase
begin
erase edilen
vektördeki
öveği için
destraktör
çağrılacak mı
tabii ki
mesela şu anda
programın akışı
arkadaşlar
döngünün
ilk durumda
pardon
buraya gelmeyi
programın akışı
kimdi o
Ahmet Delibaş
destroy edilecek
tekrar
bir
reis fonksiyonlu
çağırayım
şimdi de
Süheyla
Erdinç
bilet edilecek
isterseniz
bakın
oysa
pointer olsaydı
ham pointer olsaydı
bunları yapmaktan
ben sorumlu
olacaktım
gördüğünüz gibi
hiçbir
problem yok
arkadaşlar
bir ara verelim
saat
21.02
buyurun
çağrı
ve sorun
ondan sonra
ara verelim
ders programımızda
C++ ile
geliştirme yaparken
sıklıkla kullanılan
yardımcı araçların
kullanımı var mı
arkadaşlar
maalesef yok
yani onun için
ayrı bir
belki
zaman ayırmak
gerekiyor
çünkü çok fazla
zaman gidiyor
zaten
kursta
C++'ın
araçlarını
inceleyecek kadar
bile toplam
zamanımız yok
maalesef
onlar
kurs konularına
dahil değil
peki
saat 21.02
21.20'de
devam edecek
evet arkadaşlar
devam
bu arada bir yanlış
anlamı olmasın
Emirhan
benim demin
gösterdiğim
factory pattern
derken
eğer
nesne yönelimli
programlamadaki
tasarım kalıpları
olarak factory
pattern'den
bahsediyorsanız
arkadaşlar
factory method
tam ismi
bir de
abstract factory
var
bununla alakası
yok
C++'da biz
fabrika fonksiyonu
dediğimiz zaman
nesne oluşturan
fonksiyonlara
bu terim
nesne oluşturan
fonksiyonlar
için bu terimi
kullanıyoruz
yani bunun
factory methodla
doğrudan
bir alakası
yok
anlaşıldı
anlaşıldı mı
evet
yani işte
make pair
gibi
make tuple
make unique
gibi
make shared
fonksiyonlar
arkadaşlar
fabrika fonksiyonları
ve
standart kütüphanemiz
bunlara isim verirken
make
fiilini
kullanıyor
şimdi
kaldığımız yere
geri dönelim
ve
containerlarda
unique
ptr
nesnelerinin
tutulması
ile ilgili
önemli
bazı başka
noktalara da
değinelim
arkadaşlar
containerlar üstünde
algoritmaları
kullanıyoruz
değil mi
mesela
kopya
algoritmasını
düşünün
elimde
bir
unique ptr
containerı
daha olsa
list başlık
dosyasına
dahil ettim
ve
stutlistin
unique ptr
nin
person
açılımı
yani
person
ptr
açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
oluşturdum
container nesnesi
ve
10 tane
öğeyle
başlattım
bu
constructor
herhangi bir
sorun
yaratır mı
cevap
hayır
çünkü
unique ptr
nin
default
constructori
var
sequence
containerların
size t
parametreli
constructori
zaten
öğeyleri
default
constructor
ediyor
unique ptr
nin
default
constructori
olduğu için
bir problem
yok
şu anda
playlist isimli
containerda
10 tane
unique ptr
nesnesi var
fakat bunlar
empty state'de
boş
peki
şöyle bir kod
yazsam
copy
pvc begin
pvc end
arkadaşlar
playlist begin
sentaks
hatası
olur mu
olmaz mı
evet
burada bir
sentaks
hatası
var mı
yok mu
cevap
en az bir
arkadaşım
cevap
verirse
tabii ki
sentaks
hatası
var
neden
sentaks
hatası
var
arkadaşlar
copy
algoritması
şöyle
değil mi
defalarca
yazdık
yani
şu kısma
bakın
sadece orasını
gördüğümüzü
düşünelim
şöyle bir kod
var değil mi
arkadaşlar
var
back
eşit olmadığı
sürece
and
yıldız
back
arkadaşlar
yıldız
test
back
eşittir
yıldız
back
artı
test
back
peki
burada
copy
algoritmasında
şu kod
yürütüldüğünde
burada
unique
ptr
nesneleri
birbirine
atılacak
değil mi
Alihan
dolayısıyla
sentaks
hatası
olacak
bravo
copy
assignment
yapacak
Alihan
çok güzel
cevap
ve
sentaks
hatası
olacak
şimdi
bu kodu
legal kılmanın
bir yolu var mı
var
belki
unutmuş
olabilirsiniz
bir adaptör vardı
hatırlıyor musunuz
bu
iteratör adaptörü
arkadaşlar
move
iteratördü
eğer siz
move
iteratör
nesnelerine
d-referens
ettiğinizde
aslında
arka
planda
arkadaşlar
o iteratör
konumundaki
nesneyi
stud
move
argüman
olarak
gönderiyor
yani
bu şu
demek
eğer ben
copy'de
şuradaki
range'i
belirlerken
normal
iteratör
yerine
move
iteratör
kullanırsam
bu durumda
arkadaşlar
move
iteratör
kullandığında
eşitlerin
sağ tarafındaki
ifade
şuraya
bakınız
yani
yıldızbek
ifadesi
neye
karşılık
gelecek
bir sağ
taraf
değerine
karşılık
gelecek
orayı
anladınız mı
yani
move
iteratörün
bu konuyu
anlattım
unutmuş
olabilirsiniz
move
iteratörün
arkadaşlar
dereferencing
operatörü
aslında o
iteratör
konumundaki
nesneyi
değil
neyi
kullanıyor
onu
stud
move'a
argüman
olarak
gönderiyor
dolayısıyla
bu
sentaks
hatası
izleyiniz
çünkü
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapatılmış
olduğu için
ama bakın
kopiyi
şöyle
çağırırsam
peki
move iteratörü
nasıl
ilgi edeceğiz
tam da işte
emiram
beyin
sorusuna
bir cevap
daha
make move
iteratör isimli
bir fabrika
fonksiyonu
var
yani
make move
iteratör
fonksiyonuna
bunları
argüman
olarak
gönderirseniz
arkadaşlar
make move
iteratör
ne
geri döndürüyor
size
move
iteratörü
gönderiyor
make move
iteratör
bakınız
şimdi
bir sentaks
hatası
olmayacak
başka bir yerde
hata yapmadıysak
ama bir şeye
dikkat edin
şimdi
böylece
container
vektör
containerindeki
unique
ptr'lar
list
containerına
taşındı
değil mi
yani
tabii ki
size'da bir
değişim yok
mesela
ben şöyle
bir döngüyle
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir döngü
oluştursam
pebek
yahut
yıldız
up
ne olur
burada
kim söyleyecek
ne olur
cevap
şu olmadı
vektördeki
öğeler
taşınmış
olduğu için
vektörde tutulan
unique ptr'ler
boşa çıktı
empty set'teki
unique ptr'yi
direferans ettiğimde
tanımsız
davranış
ama bakın
şimdi
bunların
boş mu
dolu mu
olduğunu
sorgulamak için
şöyle bir kod
yazsaydım
see out
up
arkadaşlar
dolu
boş
ne yazacaktı
arkadaşlar
10 kez
boş yazacaktı
öyle değil mi
burada bir tanımsız
davranış yok
operatör
boğul fonksiyonuyla
boş mu
dolu mu
onu sınıyorum
run time'e bakın
gördüğünüz gibi
boş
peki soru
burada pv2
değil de
Alihan
Emirhan
p list'i
kullansaydım
burada 10 kez
dolu yazısı
çıkacak mıydı
cevap
tabii ki
çünkü vektörden
buradaki
copy
algoritmasına
yaptığımız
çareyle
liste
taşımış olduk
bakın
dolu
şimdi çok
dikkatli izleyin
o zaman
bir sürpriz
daha
burada
copy
make movie
iteratörü
kullanarak
yani
copy'nin
birinci
ikinci
parametresine
iteratör yerine
movie iteratör
geçmek yerine
aslında
bunu
yapan
zaten
doğrudan
bir
algoritmamız
var
o algoritmanın
ismi
move
şimdi programcıların
çok karıştırdığı
yerlerden biri de
burası
belki daha önce
bahsetmiş olabilirim
bahsetmemiş de
olabilirim
arkadaşlar
iki tane
ayrı move
fonksiyonu var
biri
bizim
taşıma
semantiği
konusundan
başlayarak
sürekli
üstünde
durduğumuz
yani
aslında
ismi move
olmak yerine
move
cast
olsa daha
iyi olurdu
dediğimiz
lvalue
expression'ı
rvalue
dönüştüren
stud move
var
o
utility
isimli
standart
başlık dosyasındaki
bir
template
bir de
arkadaşlar
algoritm
başlık dosyasında
ismi
move
olan
bir
algoritma
var
tamamen
copy gibi
fakat
copy yerine
move'u
kullandığınızda
move'un
kodu
şöyle
bakın
copy'de
kopyalama kısmı
böyle değil mi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
move'da ise
kopyalama kısmı
böyle
yani burada
move çağrısı var
dolayısıyla
copy yerine
move'u
kullanırsanız
isterseniz deneyelim
bakınız
stud move
ama bu
algoritm
başlık dosyasındaki
move
işte
şu fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
ve
argüman olarak
pevek
begin
pevekent
pelist
begin
ve taşımanın
yine
gerçekleştiğini
göreceksiniz
bakın pelistteki
öğeler
boştu
şimdi pelistteki
öğeler
dolu
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
move if yok
maalesef
ama
move if'i
şöyle yazabilirsiniz
hadi move if'i
yazalım
ya kendiniz
move if'i
yazacaksınız
arkadaşlar
ya da
make movie
iteratörle
copy if'i
kullanacaksınız
mesela
izleyin
şöyle yazalım
arkadaşlar
copy if
make move
iteratör
pevek
begin
end
arkadaşlar
make movie
iteratör
pevek
begin
make movie
iteratör
pevek
end
ilk iki
parametre
yeterli
evet
ve şimdi
üçüncü parametre
olarak
pelistteki
ve dördüncü parametre
olarak
predicate
hadi predicate
olarak da
şöyle bir şey
kullanalım
burada
unique
dtr
tutulduğunu
hatırlayın
arkadaşlar
ve
dolu olduğunu
farz ederek
şöyle bir
kod yazayım
ya da
izleyin
lambda
arkadaşlar
evet
const auto
red
up
return
doluysa
ve
diyelim ki
up
uzun uzun
yazmadım
up
get fonksiyonu
ya da
şöyle yazalım
up
person
ile ilgili bir fonksiyonumuz
var mı
evet
get name
fonksiyonu
varmış
arkadaşlar
evet
bakın
up
ok
red name
buradan bir string elde edeceğim
değil mi
up
get name
nokta
stringin nesini
yapamıyordu
şöyle yazalım
get name
köşeli parantez
sıfır
eşitse
a
takip edebiliyor muyuz
bu
copy if'in
üçüncü parametresine
gönderdiğimiz
bu da
copy if'in
dördüncü parametresine
gönderdiğimiz
arkadaşlar
unary
predicate
burada
yanlış
olmasın
authorif
up
return
ve up
get name
eşittir
demişim
eşit
a
evet
mesela şimdi
ne yapmış olacak
soruyu
Alihan
sormuştu
değil mi
arkadaşlar
boş
değilse
ve ilk harfi
a ise
listeye
taşıyacak
dolayısıyla
şimdi
tabi
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değerine de
bakman lazım
kaç tane
benin taşımdığı ile
ilgili
ama
en azından
şöyle bir kod
yazabiliriz
bakalım
kaç tanesi
taşınmış
for
most
auto
ref
up
pvek
cout
arkadaşlar
bakın bakın
count
algoritmasını
kullanalım
count
ya da
countif
algoritmasını
pvek
begin
hatta
şuradan
kopya
çekelim
pvek
end
yine
lambda
ifadesi
son
li
ip
eşit değil
bravo
şimdi poundif'in de
geri dönüşü değeri vektörde
arkadaşlar boş olmayanların
sayısı olacaktı özellikle
moveif'i kullanabilirim
ama moveif doğrudan
böyle bir algoritma yok
moveif'i
kullanmalıyım
burası anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar şimdi iki tane fonksiyon var
daha önce anlatmıştım
biri copy
diğeri de
kopyalamayı sondan başa doğru
yapan copy backwards
bunlar
modern
kütüphanemizde bulunan
iki tane algoritmaydı
ama modern c++'la birlikte
copy ile birlikte
taşıyan sürümü diyebileceğimiz
move eklendi
copy backwards yerine de
move backwards eklendi
yani copy yerine
move'u
copy backwards yerine
move backwards'ı
kullandığınız zaman
taşıma semantiğinden
faydalanıyor bu algoritmalar
evet devam
şimdi
değerli arkadaşlar
bir de şuna
değinelim ve artık
shared ptr'ye geçelim
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
bir sınıfın
veri elemanının
unique ptr
türünden olması
son derece
sık karşılaşılan
bir durum
mesela
class
my class
private
diyelim ki
unique ptr'ın
arkadaşlar
vektörün
int açılımı
şimdi elinizde
eğer
böyle bir sınıf varsa
şunları
hatırlamanız
gerekecek
arkadaşlar
bu sınıfın
copy
constructor'ı
ve copy
assignment'ı
delete edilmiş
durumda
neden copy
constructor'ı
ve copy
assignment'ı
delete edilmiş
durumda
çünkü hatırlayın
derleyici
bu fonksiyonları
default etme
girişiminde
şimdi
implicitly declared
ve default
edilecek
eğer bir
sentaks hatası
oluşursa
yani derleyicinin
implicitly declared
ettiği
örtülü olarak
bildirdiği
ve default
edeceği
yani kodunu
yazacağı
arkadaşlar
bir special
member function
sentaks hatası
oluşturursa
bu durumda
derleyici onları
deleted
olarak
bildiriyordu
yani
şu anda
bu sınıfın
default
constructor'ı
var mı
cevap
var
yani default
constructor'ın
ve destructor'ın
derleyici tarafından
default edilmesine
bir problem yok
copy
constructor'ı
ve copy
assignment'ı
var mı
var
ama
delete edilmiş
durumda
isterseniz
görün
bakın
my
class
m1
auto
m2
eşit bir
m1
derleyici
nasıl bir
sentaks hatası
verecek
delete edilmiş
olan
copy
constructor'a
çağrı
yapıldığı
için
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
bakın
arkadaşlar
copy
constructor'ı
atıfta
bulunuyor
ve diyor ki
attempting to
reference
deleted function
aynı şekilde
atama operatör fonksiyonu
kopyalayan
da delete edilmiş
durumda
peki
soru
bu soru
önemli
stud
move
m1
auto
m2
m3
ve
m2
eşittir
arkadaşlar
stud
move
diyelim ki
m3
27 ve
28.
satırdaki
kodlar
sentaks hatası
oluşturur mu
bu aslında
ne demek
yani
my class'ın
move
constructor'ı
ve move
assignment'ı
var mı
cevap
var
çünkü
derleyicinin
yazdığı
move
constructor
ve move
assignment
bir
sentaks
hatası
oluşturmuyor
sentaks
hatası
oluşturmadığı
için
arkadaşlar
kod
legal
anlaşıldı mı
evet
o zaman
gerektiği
noktada
tekrar
unique
ptr
sınıfına
geri dönme
hakkımız
olmakla
birlikte
şimdi
bizi
biraz daha
zorlayacak
share ptr
sınıfına
başlayacağız
arkadaşlar
yavaş yavaş
başlayalım
bir kere
share ptr'de
unique ptr
gibi
a bir
smart pointer
sınıfı
b
standart
kütüphanenin
bir sınıfı
c
yine
unique ptr'de
olduğu gibi
memory
başlık
dosyasında
tanımlanmış
dolayısıyla
share ptr
sınıfını
jenerik
kullanmak
için de
yine
memory
başlık
dosyasını
include
etmem
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
yalnız
share ptr
a
adı üstünde
paylaşımlı
sahiplik
stratejisini
implemente ediyor
yani
örneğin
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesnenin
birden fazla
sahibi olabilir
pointer
sözde pointer
smart pointer
aynı
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
gösteriyor
olabilir
dolayısıyla
kopyalamaya
karşı
bırakın
kapalı
olmasını
burada
zaten
kopyalama
sağlanan
hizmetlerin
en önemlerinden
biri
share ptr
nesneleri
kopyalanabilir
yani
örneğin
ben
bir share ptr
nesnesinin
dinamik bir
string nesnesini
göstermesini
sağlayıp
sonra
share ptr
nesnesinin
10 tane
daha
kopyasını
çıkartabilirim
arkadaşlar
burada
İngilizce'de
reference counting
dediğimiz
teknik
uygulanarak
oraya
geleceğiz
bir kaynağı
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
gösteren
birden fazla
share pointer
olabilir
share ptr
nesnesi
olabilir
ama bu
share ptr
nesnelerinden
herhangi birinin
hayatı
bitince
nesne
dirilt edilmeyecek
ta ki
en son
share ptr
nesnesi
arkadaşlar
destroy
edildiğinde
yani
kaynağı gösteren
tek bir share ptr
nesnesi
kalmışsa
ve onun
destraktörü
çağrıldığında
o destraktör
birazdan konuşacağımız
üzere
kaynağı gösteren
son share ptr
nesnesi
olduğunu
anlayacak
ve kaynağı
sonlandıracak
delete edecek
burada
böylece
farklı farklı
kodlarda
aynı
dinamik ömürlü
nesneye
pointerlar
tutabileceğiz
arkadaşlar
peki burada
nasıl bir yapı var
arkadaşlar
burası biraz
karmaşık
ama
şöyle basitçe
anlatmaya
çalışalım
izleyin
şuraya
yeni bir sayfa
açalım
arkadaşlar
share ptr
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
eğer
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
örneğin
gösteriyorsa
aslında
içinde
bir tane
pointer yerine
iki tane
pointer tutuyor
pointerlardan
biri
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
kendisine
yani
bu da
bizim
dinamik ömürlü
nesnemiz
olsun
fakat
şu
bizim
share ptr
nesnemiz
olsun
share ptr
nesnemizin
içindeki
pointerlardan
biri
tıpkı
unic ptr
olduğu gibi
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
gösterecek
fakat
diğer pointer
ingilizce'de
control block
denilen
aslında
derleyici
tarafından
oluşturulan
o derleyiciye
göre bir nesne
bir bloğu
gösterecek
ki
o blokta
tipik olarak
bizi şimdilik
ilgilendiren
hadi
bu da
control blok
dediğimiz
blok olsun
control blokta
birden fazla
üve tutuluyor
şerit ptr'nin
türünün
ne olduğuna
bağlı olarak
fakat
bunların içinde
en önemlisi
reference count
dediğimiz
değişken
şöyle yazayım
biraz da
pontu
küçültelim
evet
reference count
arkadaşlar
işte
bakınız
eğer
benim
şerit
nesnem
pointer
şerit ptr
nesnem
kaynağı gösteren
tek şerit
pointer ise
buradaki
reference
counter'ın
değeri
bir
ama
aynı
kaynağı
gösteren
birden fazla
şerit ptr
nesnesi varsa
o zaman
her bir
şerit ptr
nesnesi için
reference
count
bir arttırılmış
durumda
mesela iki tane
pointer varsa
arkadaşlar
aynı kaynağı
gösteren
kontrol
bloğundaki
referans
sayıcımızın
değeri
iki
böylece
bir şerit ptr
nesnesi
içindeki
kontrol
bloğunu
gösteren
arkadaşlar
pointer
vasıtasıyla
kontrol
bloğuna
erişebiliyor
ve
kontrol
bloğundaki
bu
referans
sayıcı
İngilizce
reference
counting
dediğimiz
değişkenin
değerine
bakarak
nesneyi
gösteren
dinamik
ömürlü
nesneyi
gösteren
kaç tane
pointer
olduğunu
anlıyor
örneğin
bizim
şerit ptr
nesnemiz
kaynağı
gösteren
son
pointer
ise
o zaman
buradaki
sayıç
bir
olacak
destraktır
bu sayıcı
bir
azaltacak
bütün
şerit ptr
nesneler
için
destraktır
referans
sayıcını
bir
azaltıyor
konstraktır
da
kaynağı
gösteren
bir
yapıda
ise
referans
sayıcını
bir
arttırıyor
son
şerit ptr
nesnesi
için
referans
sayıcı
sıfır
olacak
eksiltme
işleminden
sonra
bu durumda
şerit ptr
destraktır
kaynağı
delete
edecek
şimdi
buradan çıkan
önemli bir
sonuç
bir kere
şerit ptr
unique ptr
gibi
arkadaşlar
zero cost
abstraction
kesinlikle
değil
yani
şerit ptr
kullandığınız zaman
bazı
ilave maliyetleri
yüklenmiş
oluyorsunuz
yani
buna size
bir zararı
olabilir
ya da
olmayabilir
bir kere
bellek açısından
zaten
tipik olarak
bir
pointer
fazlası
var
isterseniz
bakalım
arkadaşlar
izleyin
mesela
string başlık
dosyasını
dahil edeyim
ve
size of
iostream
başlık
dosyasını
dahil
edelim
size of
unique ptr'ın
string açılımı
tane pointer tutuyor. Ama
shared pointer arkadaşlar
shared PTR
iki tane pointer tutuyor.
Biri kontrol
bloğunu gösterecek. Biri
ise dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi gösterecek.
Biz shared pointer nesnesini
dereferans ettiğimizde
içindeki dinamik
ömürlü nesneyi gösteren pointer
vasıtasıyla bizi
hayatını kontrol ettiği nesneyi
eriştiriyor. Ama kendisi de
kontrol bloğuna
diğer pointer vasıtasıyla
erişip örneğin kontrol
bloğundaki referans sayıcını
update edebiliyor.
Ya da oradaki
değeri get edebiliyor. Ama orada
kontrol bloğunda
bazı nedenlerden dolayı
başka öğeler de var. Şimdi birazdan
göstereceğim. Ama önce
bu programı
değerleyip çalıştıralım.
Ve shared PTR
sınıfının
bende bir pointer size of'u
4 byte hatta
onu da gösterin.
Üçü birlikte olsun.
Size of
string yıldız.
Yani
ham pointer size of'u
arkadaşlar.
Unique PTR
ve shared PTR.
evet bakın
4, 4 ve
8.
Arkadaşlar
ikinci önemli farklılık
ya da üçüncü önemli
farklılık
shared PTR
sınıfı
bir
jenerik sınıf
pointerlar
türden bağım
step aynı size mi?
Evet.
Evet arkadaşlar.
Şimdi
Alihan'ın sorusuna
biraz daha
kapsamlı cevap vereyim.
C'de de böyle.
Öncelikle
pointerlar
iki ana kategoriye
ayrılıyor.
Bir kategoriye
object pointers
diyoruz.
Arkadaşlar
diğer kategoriye
function pointers
diyoruz.
Object pointer'ın
size of'u
aynı.
Function pointer'ın
size of'u
aynı.
Ama bir object
pointer'ın size of'u
ile bir function
pointer'ın size of'unun
aynı olma garantisi
yok.
Aynen.
Anlaşıldı
değil mi?
Evet.
Peki.
Şimdi
kaldığımız yere
geri dönelim.
Shep PTR
sınıf
şablonunun
yani
jenerik
Shep PTR
sınıfının
Unique PTR'den
bir başka farklılığı
burada
deleter
parametresi yok.
Yani
bakın
Unique PTR'de
Default
argüman
olarak
arkadaşlar
Default
delete'in
T açılımı
alan
ikinci bir
template
parametresi var.
Ama
Shep PTR'ye
bakarsanız
Shep PTR'nin
sadece ve
sadece
bir tane
tamtik
parametresi var.
Yanlış anlaşılmasın
bu
Shep PTR
nesneleri
söz konusu
olduğunda
son kalan
Shep PTR'nin
kaynağı
sonlandırması
için
Default
delete'i
yani
delete
operatörünü
kullanma
mecburiyeti
getirmiyor.
Farklılık
şurada
burada
bir
liter için
liter'ı
Constructor'a
argüman
olarak
geçiyoruz.
Buraya
dikkat
tekrar
söylüyorum.
Template
parametresi yok
delete'er
parametresi
ama
Constructor
bizden
delete'er'ı
argüman
olarak
alıyor.
Arkadaşlar
ileri kursda
detaylı
anlattığım
Hyperager
dediğimiz
bir konu
var.
Yani
Türkçe'ye
birebir
çevirirsek
tip silme.
Standart
kütüphanemizin
bazı
üyeleri
öyle ya da
böyle
Hyperager'dan
faydalanıyor.
Örneğin
Shared
PTR
sınıfı
böyle.
Nasıl
oluyor da
biz
tür argümanı
olarak
bir
delete'er
türü
vermesek de
Shared
PTR
nesnelere
nasıl
delete
edeceğini
biliyorlar.
Türün
bir parçası
olmamasına
rağmen.
Çünkü
Constructor
yoluyla
delete'er
alıp
Type
Erasure
tekneyiyle
o delete'er
gizlemiş
oluyorlar.
Yani
statik olarak
derneme
zamanında
baktığınızda
sanki
bir delete'er
türü
yokmuş
gibi
ama
aslında
delete'er
türü
Constructor
yoluyla
edinilen
arkadaşlar
yani
Constructor'a
gönderdiğiniz
argümandan
belirleniyor.
burada
kullanılan
tekne
Hyper
Erasure
deniyor.
Yani
şöyle
değil mi?
Örneğin
Shared
PTR'nin
String
açılımı
böyle bir
Shared
Pointer
değişkenimiz
olabilir
ama
diyelim ki
ben özel
bir delete'er
kullanmak
için
Shared
PTR'nin
Constructor'ına
örneğin
New
String
Ahmet
ama
bakın
Constructor'ın
ikinci
parametresine
arkadaşlar
String
Yıldız
e
delete
tabi
orjinal
zaten
böyle
default
delete
böyle bir
argüman
gönderebilirim.
Yedinci
hocam
burada
her pointer'a
farklı bir
delete'er
imkanı mı
veriliyor
yanlış
anlamadıysam
arkadaşlar
yani ben böyle
ifade etmezdim
ama
hiçbir yanlış
anlamı yok.
Evet
her
Shared
Pointer
nesnesini
oluştururken
onun
Constructor'ına
bir
delete'er'ı
argüman olarak
verebilirsiniz.
Ama
bu yazdığınız
kodun
doğru olduğu
anlamına
gelmiyor.
Ne
şekilde
kullandığınıza
bağlı.
Birazdan
geleceğiz
oraya.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
yavaş yavaş
Shared
PTR
sınıfını
tanımaya
başlayalım.
Yine
Unique
PTR'de
olduğu gibi
Shared
PTR'de de
isterseniz yine
Person
sınıfını
kullanalım.
Az önce
alıştık
onu
kullanmaya.
Include
yani herhangi bir
sınıf olduğu için
Person
Shared
PTR'nin
Person
açılımı
arkadaşlar
SP
Şimdi
bakınız
Bunlar
üye fonksiyonlar.
Üye fonksiyonları
tek tek
göreceğiz.
Gördüğümüz gibi
arkadaşlar
Operatör
Bull
fonksiyonu
İçerik
Operatör
fonksiyonu
Ok
Operatör
fonksiyonu
Atama
Operatör
fonksiyonu
Array
Partial
Specialization
Köşeli
Parantez
Operatör
fonksiyonu
Get
Reset
fonksiyonu
Swap
Use
Count
fonksiyonu
var.
Takip
edebildik mi?
Arkadaşlar
önce
bu fonksiyonlardan
Use
Count'u
bir görelim.
Bir
Shared
PTR
nesnesinin
Use
Count
fonksiyonu
adı
üstünde
referans
sayıcını
arkadaşlar
döndürüyor.
Yani
onun gösterdiği
kaynağı
gösteren
kaç tane
Shared
PTR var?
Mesela
bakınız
See
Out
bir tane
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
göstersin
New
Person
Alihan
Bozkır
Şimdi
See
Out
SP'nin
Use
Count'u
eşittir.
Yani
Use
Count
fonksiyonundan
geri dönüştüğü
yeri
eşittir.
Arkadaşlar
SP
nokta
Use
Count
Kaç
olacak
şu anda
Yiğit
Alihan
Diğer
arkadaşlarım
Mehmet
Can
Bey
Cevap
Çünkü
bir tane
pointer gösteriyor.
Evet
Ama
şimdi
bakın
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapalı
değil.
Yani
Oto
buna
SP1
diyelim
ve
artık
diğer
share
pointerlarımızı
oluşturalım.
Oto
SP2
eşittir
SP1
Oto
SP3
eşittir
SP2
Arkadaşlar
Peki
soru
şimdi
ben
19.
satırda
SP2
için
Use
Count'u
çağırsam
SP1
için
Use
Count'u
çağırsam
SP3
için
Use
Count'u
çağırsam
Bunların
hepsi
aynı
değeri
döndürecek
değil mi?
Çünkü
aynı
kaynağı
gösteriyorlar.
Şu anda
referans
sayıcı
kaç oldu?
Arkadaşlar
3 oldu.
Yani
buraya
geldiğimizde
fonksiyon
çağrısı da
değerini
döndürecek.
Çünkü
kaynağı
gösteren
3 tane
shared
pointer var.
Süper
devam.
Arkadaşlar
mesela
bunu
şöyle bir
blok içine
alsaydım
ve
bu
blokun
içinde
SP3'ün
Use
Count
değerini
yazdırsaydım
fakat
bloktan
çıktıktan
sonra
SP1'in
ve
SP2'nin
Use
Count
değerlerini
yazdırsaydım
ilk
yazacak
değer
olacaktı
ama
ondan sonra
2 tane
yazacaktı
çünkü
SP3'ün
hayatı
bittiğinde
SP3'ün
referans
sayıcı
SP3'ün
destraktörü
referans
sayıcını
1 eksiltecekti.
Burayı
herkes
anladı mı?
görüyoruz
değil mi?
Evet
Son
Unique
PTR
nesnesinin
destraktörü
çağrıldığında
aynı
kaynağı
gösteren
Son
Unique
PTR
nesnesinin
destraktörü
önce
referans
sayıcını
azaltacak
eksiltecek
referans
sayıcının
0 olduğunu
gördüğünde
dinamik
ömürlü
nesneyi
arkadaşlar
delete
edecek
şimdi
önce
şu fonksiyonlarımıza
bir bakalım
dedik
use
count'u
gördük
arkadaşlar
reset
fonksiyonu
bakınız
Evet
SP1
basımı
sildik
şuraya
kadar
neyse
otu
SP2
eşittir
SP1
otu
SP3
eşittir
SP2
Şimdi dikkat
burada
reset fonksiyonu var
ama
reset fonksiyonu
tabii ki
Unique PTR'de
olduğu gibi
ne yapmıyor
kaynağı
sonlandırmıyor
sadece
o
SHELT PTR
nesnesini
artık o
kaynağı
göstermez
yani boş
hale
getiriyor
dolayısıyla
bakınız
Cout
arkadaşlar
SP3
use count
Fakat
örneğin
SP2
reset
ondan sonra
tekrar
SP3'ün
use count
unu
çağırıyorum
derliyorum
çalıştırıyorum
gördüğünüz gibi
üçgen
2'ye düştü
yani
reset fonksiyonu
kaynağı sonlandırmıyor
ama
tabii ki
izleyin
biraz kodu
değiştirelim
SP2
reset
arkadaşlar
SP1
reset
şuraya
get car
çağrısını
koyalım
boy
get car
sadece
bakınız
get car'a
geldiğinde
nesnemiz
destroy edilmemiş
durumda
çünkü
onu gösteren
halen bir
SHELT
PTR
nesnesi var
ama
SP3
için de
reset'i
çağırsaydım
artık
SP3
de boşa
çıkacağı
için
yine
arkadaşlar
nesnemiz
destroy
edilecekti
yani
reset
fonksiyonu
SHELT PTR'nin
hayatı devam
ederken
o bir
kaynağı
gösteriyorsa
onun
kaynakla
ilişkisini
kesecek
SHELT PTR
nesnesini
boş hale
koyacak
ve
referans
sayıcını
bir
eksiltecek
arkadaşlar
evet
yine
izleyin
arkadaşlar
bir tane
nesnemiz
olsun
SP1'in
GET
fonksiyonu
dikkat ederseniz
tıpkı
UNIQ PTR'de
olduğu gibi
adres döndürüyor
yani
GET fonksiyonu
kaynağa geri
vermiyor
ama
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
adresini
döndürüyor
içerik
operatör
fonksiyonu
OTO
SP2
eşit bir
SP1
arkadaşlar
dinamik ömürlü
nesneye
erişimi
sağlıyor
yıldız
SP1
tabi
ben hep
dinamik ömürlü
nesnediyorum
ama
onları
konuştuk
illa bir
NİB
operatörüyle
oluşturulmuş
nesne olması
gerekmiyor
onları
biliyoruz
artık
her defasında
o uzun cümleyi
tekrar etmek
istemiyorum
şimdi artık
aynı
nesneye
gördüğünüz gibi
arkadaşlar
girden fazla
pointerla
erişebilirim
arkadaşlar
bu da
müthiş bir
imkan
bakın
farklı farklı
kodlarda
da olabilir
aynı
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
adresini
aynı
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
gösteren
shape pointerı
bir fonksiyona
gönderirsiniz
mesela
o fonksiyon
ona bir
konteynera
koyabilir
aynı
shape
ptr
nesnesini
arkadaşlar
farklı
konteynerlarda
shape
ptr
nesneleri
tutarak
farklı
konteynerlarda
aynı
dinamik ömürlü
nesneye
erişebilirsiniz
öyle değil mi
evet
yine
burada
dikkat ederseniz
sp1'in
arkadaşlar
operatör
boğul fonksiyonu
da var
yani
shape ptr
ninin
dolu mu
boş mu
olduğunu
yine
operatör
boğul fonksiyonu
ile
test edebilirsiniz
örneğin
if
sp1
see out
dolu
else
sp1
boş
ama
sp1'e
a
arkadaşlar
farklı bir şerit
ptr nesnesine
atarsam
ve
sp1'i
için
reset
fonksiyonu
çağırırsam
arkadaşlar
bakın
şunların hepsi
boş duruma koyacak
sp1
reset
sp1'e
başka bir şerit ptr
nesnesi atarsanız
o boştur
bu durumda
yine boşa çıkacak
ya da
sp1'e
bifold
konstrakt edilmiş
bir şerit ptr
nesnesi atarsanız
yine
boşa çıkacak
dolayısıyla
tekrar böyle bir
if deyim
yazarsam
bu sefer
boş
olduğunu
göreceğiz
yine
boş bir şerit ptr
nesnesine
arkadaşlar
d-referans etmek
unic ptr'de
olduğu gibi
tanımsız
davranış
arkadaşlar
yalnız burada
önemli bir konu var
bakın şimdi
tekrar şuradaki
resme geri dönecek
olursak
burada
hayati önem
taşıyan
bizim doğrudan
görmediğimiz
bir kontrol bloğu
var
o kontrol bloğu
belirli durumlarda
oluşturuluyor
mesela bakın
çok dikkatli izleyin
ben şimdi size
konuyu daha iyi
takip edebilmenizi
sağlamak için
daha önce
yaptığım gibi
bir
operatör
new
fonksiyonu
yazacağım
arkadaşlar
operatör
new ve
delete
fonksiyonları var
görüyorsunuz
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
bu ne demek
birer
kontrol bloğu oluşmuşsa
kontrol bloğu da
dinamik olarak
oluşturuluyor
değil mi
o kontrol bloğu için
yine
ben
operatör
new
fonksiyonunun
çağrıldığını
görmeliyim
bakınız
share
ptr
arkadaşlar
person
sptr
soru
herhangi bir şekilde
operatörün
new fonksiyonu
çağrılacak mı
cevap
hayır
çünkü
dinamik ömürlü bir nesne
oluşturmadım
ve bir kontrol bloğuna da
ihtiyaç yok
ama şimdi bakın
arkadaşlar
share ptr
new
buraya dikkat
string
person'dan vazgeçtim
share ptr'nin string açılımı
new string
bakın şimdi
burayı çok dikkatli
izlemenizi istiyorum
void
headcur
terliyorum
neden iki tane
dinamik berlek bloğu
allocate edildi
biri
arkadaşlar
string
dinamik ömürlü
string nesnesi için
yani
16 olan
aslında
dinamik ömürlü
string nesnesi için
ayrılan alan
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
peki
ikincisi
nerede
o da
kontrol bloğu
için
deniz diyor ki
içinde iki tane
pointer vardı
pointer değil
tipik olarak
üç tane pointer
olabilir ama
implementasyona bağlı
bir de
small buffer
optimization
olabilir
anlaşıldı değil mi
burada 24
kimin için
çağrıldı
ilk yazan 24
arkadaşlar
aslında
dinamik ömürlü
string nesnesi için
yani şuradaki
new string için
ama diğer 16
o kontrol bloğu için
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
bakın şimdi
auto
sptr2
eşittir sptr1
arkadaşlar
şimdi artık bir daha
kontrol bloğu
oluşmayacak
değil mi
yani
aynı kaynağı
gösteren
şerptr'ler için
bir tane
kontrol bloğu var
şimdi
kontrol bloğunun
oluşması için
sizin bir
şerptr nesnesi
oluşturmanız
gerekiyor
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
yani onun da
boş olmaması
gerekiyor
boşsa
niye kontrol
bloğu oluşturulsun
iki
eğer bir
unique ptr
nesnesiyle
bir şerptr
nesnesini
hayata
başlatırsanız
böyle bir
konstruktör olduğunu
söylemiştim ya
örnek
arkadaşlar
unique
ptr
string açılımı
uptr
niv
arkadaşlar
string
bakın şimdi
şuraya
özellikle
hep
etkar çarşısını
koyuyorum
debugger gibi
kullanmak için
derliyorum
24 byte
dinamik ömürlü
string nesnesi
için ama şimdi
bakın
şerptr'nin
string açılımı
sptr
arkadaşlar
mu
uptr
biget card çağrısı
buraya
biget card çağrısı da
şunu da kapatalım
kapatalım
arkadaşlar
bakın
bu
dinamik ömürlü
string nesnesi için
ama şimdi
şerptr nesnesini
oluşturduğumda
onu bir
unique ptr
ile
konstrukt etsem
dahi
sonuçta bir
kontrol
bloğuna
ihtiyaç var
şimdi
kontrol
bloğu
oluştu
arkadaşlar
takip edebildik
mi
şimdi burada
optimizasyon
derliğicilerin
yaptığı
optimizasyon
açısından
çok önemli
bir fonksiyon
var
nasıl
unique ptr
için
make unique
fabrika
fonksiyonu
varsa
share ptr
içinde
make shared
fabrika
fonksiyonu
var
yani örneğin
siz
make shared
fonksiyonunu
şöyle
çağırabilirsiniz
make shared
tıpkı
unique ptr
olduğu gibi
person
arkadaşlar
efendim
niv
person
ali
aksoy
yine
make shared'in
person
açılımının
geri dönüş
değeri
tabii ki
shared ptr
person
açılımı
yani şöyle
auto
sp
desem
sp'nin
türü
shared ptr
person
açılımı
arkadaşlar
şimdi
unique ptr
de
make unique
sadece bir
yazma kolaylığı
sağlıyor
ama
shared ptr
de durum
öyle değil
shared ptr
daki
make shared
fonksiyonu
şöyle bir
optimizasyona
olanak sağlıyor ki
bu çok önemli
bir optimizasyon
arkadaşlar
bakınız
eğer şöyle bir
kod yazarsam
koda dikkat edin
şimdi
string
yıldız p
eşittir
new
string
arkadaşlar
şimdi sadece
string
nesnesi için
dinamik bir
bellek bloğu
elde edildi
değil mi
yani
operatör
new
fonksiyonu
çağrıldı
word get car
şimdi
ben
bu
dinamik
ömürlü
nesneyle
bir
shared ptr
nesnesini
oluşturursam
shared ptr
nesnesini
string
açılımı
sp
t
arkadaşlar
şimdi de
kontrol
bloğu için
ayrı bir
dinamik
bellek
bloğu
elde edilecek
bakın
iki kere
operatör
new'in
çağrıldığını
göreceğiz
şimdi
operatör
new
fonksiyonunun
iki kere
çağrılması
yani iki
ayrı
dinamik
bellek
bloğunun
allocate
edilmesi
bir
maliyet
kaybı
çünkü
gerçekten
dinamik
bellek
alanı
allocate
etmek
ciddi
bir
maliyete
sahip
arkadaşlar
bunu
göstermek
için
hatta
string
sınıfını
değil
farklı
bir
sınıf
kullanayım
bakın
şimdi
arkadaşlar
struct
match
bir tane
buffer tutsun
char
buck
bölge
daha da
iyi anlayacaksınız
şimdi
bakın
arkadaşlar
share
ptr'nin
neydi
ismi
neç
açılımı
sbtr
ama
buna
argüman
olarak
new
neç
geçiyorum
şu anda
iki tane
allocation
garanti
biri
dinamik ömürlü
neç
nesnesi
için
arkadaşlar
öbürü de
kontrol
bloğu
için
takip
edebildik mi
ve
açıklama
yapmaya
gerek yok
arkadaşlar
oysa
bakın
hatta
şu
operator
delete'i
de
silelim
kapa
karıştırmasın
tabi ki
kod doğru
olmayacak
ama
arkadaşlar
oysa
bakın
şimdi
eğer
ben
make
share
fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
make
share
net
ve
bu kadar
geri dönüş
değerini
bir share
PPR
meselesinde
sakladım
bu
garanti
altında
değil
ama
derleyicilerin
hemen
hepsi
ben bu
optimizasyonu
yapmayan
derleyici
görmedim
tabi
sığ işlerine
dikkat
burada
make share
de çağırdığınızda
şöyle bir
optimizasyon
yapıyorlar
arkadaşlar
aslında
bir
unique
PTR
dinamik
ömürlü
nesnesi
işte o
şu olsun
bunun için
bir allocation
yapılacak
new ifadesiyle
normalde
bir de
kontrol
bloğu için
bakın
ilk örneğimizde
bunlar ayrı ayrı
allocate ediliyordu
ama
make share
zaten
fonksiyon olduğu
için
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
make share
içindeki
kod oluşturduğu
için
nasıl bir
optimizasyon
yapma
şansına
sahip
arkadaşlar
tane
yani gidecek
bir kere
allocation
yapacak
toplam
alan için
allocate
ettiği
bellek
block
arkadaşlar
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin storage'ı
olarak kullanacak
bir kısmını da
niçin kullanacak
arkadaşlar
kontrol
block
için kullanacak
gerçekten de
derneğin
bu optimizasyonu
kolaylıkla
yapabildiğini
göreceksiniz
izleyin
normalde şu anda
artı
olması
gerekiyor
değil mi
izleyin
arkadaşlar
bakın
artı
byte'lık
bir
allocation
yapmak
yerine
make share
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
share
pointer
nesnesini
oluşturduğumda
tek bir
kez
operatör
new
fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yapıldığını
gördünüz
orayı
anladık mı
evet
o zaman buraya
kadar bir
toparlayalım
yavaş yavaş
biraz zorlaşacak
çünkü konu
bu iki blok
contiguous mu
tabii ki
contiguous olmadan
bunu yapma
şansı yok
çünkü eğer
contiguous olmasaydı
onu tek bir
operatör
new çağrısıyla
iki ayrı
bernek bloğunu
allocate etme
imkanı
olmayacaktı
ama arkadaşlar
bu ciddi
deniz diyor ki
ben mi yanlış
hesapladım
beklerdim
hayır
işte
1024 artı
arkadaşlar
ama
tabii burada
derleyicinin
yazdığı
kodda
o dinamik
bellek bloğunun
büyüklüğünü
kendisi
hesaplıyor
yani o
anladınız
değil mi
yani o tamamen
derleyiciye bağlı
önemli olan
burada
neyi görmemiz
iki tane mi
allocation oldu
bir tane mi
cevap
iki tane
ayrı allocation
olmuştu
ben
make share'de
kullanmadığımda
ama make share'de
kullandığımda
bir tane
allocation oldu
evet
arkadaşlar
o zaman
devam
use count
fonksiyonuyla
referans sayıcını
get edebiliyoruz
dedik
get fonksiyonuyla
adresi alabiliyoruz
tıpkı
unic.ptr'de
olduğu gibi
burada da
share.ptr için
bir
o stream
insörter'ı var
yani
adresi
doğrudan
get fonksiyonuyla
alıp
onu stream'e
vermekle
share.ptr
nesnesini
doğrudan
stream'e
verdiğimizde
yine
kaynağın
adresini
yazdırmış oluyoruz
arkadaşlar
share.ptr
nesnesi
share.ptr'in
bakın
unic.ptr'nin
void açılımı
kullanılabilir değil
çünkü
bilet ederken
complete type
olması gerekiyor
oysa
void
bir complete type
değil
yani
şöyle bir
kod yazdığınızda
arkadaşlar
unic.ptr'ın
void açılımı
diyelim ki
new
person
bakın
sentax hatası
çünkü
aslında
sentax hatası
hangi noktada
var
arkadaşlar
unic.ptr
nesnesinin
destructor'ında
unic.ptr'nin
destructor'ı
bu durumda
bir void
pointer'ı
destroy etmek
zorunda
o da
incomplete
type
olduğu için
yani
arkadaşlar
delete
operatörünün
operanda
incomplete
type
olduğu için
sentax
hatası
oldu
ama bu
bir
share.ptr
nesnesi
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
share.ptr'nin
void açılımı
sp1
share.ptr'nin
void açılımı
sp2
share.ptr'nin
void açılımı
sp3
örneğin
near
int
bunların
hepsi
geçerli
arkadaşlar
yine
unic.ptr'de
olduğu gibi
share.ptr'nin
de
area specialization'ı
var
yani bu açıdan
yine
unic.ptr'ye
benziyor
o zaman
şöyle madde
madde
söylersek
kopyalamaya
karşı
arkadaşlar
yanlış
anlaşılmasın
taşımaya
karşı da
açık
kopyalamaya
karşı
açık
olması
taşımaya
karşı
kapalı
olduğu
anlamına
gelmiyor
ama
örneğe
bakın
şimdi
hatta
şöyle
yazalım
using
yine
person
ptr
eşittir
bu sefer
share ptr'nin
person
açılımı
bakın
şimdi
person
ptr
p1
eşittir
e1
near
person
elin
karabınır
person
ptr
p2
arkadaşlar
near
person
ahmet
aksoy
bunlar
aynı türden
nesneler
değil mi
örneğin
p1
eşittir
p2
yazabilirim
arkadaşlar
p1
eşittir
p2
dediğimde
p1'in
use count'u
1 artacak
ama
p2'yi
gösteren
nesnelerin de
use count'u
1 eksilecek
burada
p2
son nesne
olduğu için
ahmet
aksoy
delete
edilecek
şöyle
yapalım
otu
p3
eşittir
p2
şimdi
p1
eşittir
p2
c6
p1'in
use
count'u
p2'nin
use
count'u
gördüğünüz gibi
arkadaşlar
p1'in use
count'u
p2'nin use
ikisi de
ama
şöyle yapalım
taşıma semantini örnek verelim
oto
p1
eşittir
p2
oto
eşittir
p1
özlemini
oto p3
eşittir
p2
şimdi
mesela şöyle yazsam
p1
eşittir
arkadaşlar
mu
p2
p2'yi p1'e taşıdığımda
arkadaşlar
ne olacak
p2
referans sayıcını
bir eksiltecek
eğer örneğin
p1
boş bir
şerp
p3 nesnesi
olsaydı
ya da başka bir tane
alalım
şerp
p3'nin
person
açılımı
şöyle olsun
p4
tamam
şimdi
use
count'u
alalım
3 oldu
değil mi
evet
see out
p1'in
use count'u
get
car
şimdi
uygam
p4
eşittir
mu
p1
p4'ün
use
count'u
terleyip
çalıştırıyorum
p4
eşittir
mu
get
karı
kopyalayacaktım
tamam
evet
bakın
yine
neden
çünkü
biri
taşıdığım
referans sayıcını
biraz alttı
ama
diğerine taşıdığım için
referans sayıcı
yine
1 arttı
ya da
şimdi şuna
bakın
fonksiyonun
parametresi
void
fo
person
pd
fonksiyonun
içinde
referans sayıcının
değerini yazdırıyorum
siyah
p'nin
use
count'u
p1'in use
count'unu
yazdırıyorum
yukarıdaki fonksiyonu
çağırıyorum
full
p1
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonu çağırdıktan sonra
tekrar use
count'u
çağırdım
evet
alan diyor ki
kontrol bloğunun içinde
sadece referans sayıcı mı
var
hayır
şimdi bu zor bir soru
kontrol bloğunun içinde
arkadaşlar
diliter ile ilgili
bir öğe var
ve tipik olarak
bu size biraz tuhaf gelse de
kontrol bloğunun içinde
yine dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin adresi var
yani dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin adresi
hem şerh ptr nesnesinin içinde
ama aynı zamanda
ileride
ileride derken artık
bir dahaki derste
öğreneceğimiz bir nedenle
kontrol bloğunun içinde de
dinamik ömürlü nesnenin adresi var
yani kontrol bloğunun içinde
tipik olarak
bir dinamik ömürlü nesnenin adresi
iki referans sayıcı
3 diliter'e eriştirmek için
yine bir öğe
var diye düşünebilirsiniz
tabii kısmı da derleyiciye bağlı
derleyici implementasyona bağlı
başka öğelerde
olabilir
evet yani burada
kontrol bloğunun bir maliyeti var
onu yine vurgulamış olalım
evet bakın
3'tü 4'e çıktı
fonksiyon çağrıldığında
fonksiyonun parametre değişkeni de
şerh ptr olduğu için
referans sayıcını bir arttırdı
fakat fonksiyonun kodunun
çalışmasından sonra
parametre değişkeninin
hayatı bittiği için
parametre değişkeni için
destraktör çağrılacak
çağrılan destraktör
referans sayıcını
bir eksiltecek
yine
peki arkadaşlar
hepinizin yeni yılını
kutluyorum
ama çarşamba günü
yine dersimiz var
yarın resmi tatil
fakat çarşamba günü
dersimiz var
o zaman çarşamba günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
arkadaşlar
iyi akşamlar diliyorum
hoşçakalın
nice mutlu yıllar
abone ol
iyi akşamlar